two hello everybody it is Monday
June 12th
of the beautiful holy God year of 2023.
and I'll tell you this
if you watched last week's shows you
know that they weren't very good
and that's you know thank you Olivia we
try our best every week week after week
and you know we make a lot of content
and last week's I'll be honest they were
they were just subpar shows they weren't
good
but having gone over our show today I
can assure you all
that this is gonna be a fantastic show
and I'm so glad you guys are all here
this is going to be a really good show
let's go
unlike last week's
uh today we are spons we have no
sponsors
[Applause]
and this is how we do it the live show
is right around the corner OMG what the
f it's in 11 days bro it's next Friday
I'm stressing you are there's a lot to
do there's a lot to [__] do bro we go
we do go all out on our live stream
you need help you got it I need so much
help you know what I mean do we need no
I'm being a little over dramatic but uh
yeah there's just a lot to do there's a
lot to do
but uh we got two weeks
so plenty of time in in this industry
that's an insanity it's a fortnight
oh wow that is true actually
yeah but um so
yeah I'm excited we've we've we've done
some really exciting things for the show
and that's part of the fun thing I guess
this is our second like big live show or
maybe our third one if you count the one
a long time ago I don't know but we we
go out with that one yeah we went all
out for that one too
so anyway we look forward to seeing you
guys there thank you thank you also
shout out to Teddy fresh Marvel here's a
cool ass Ghost Rider shirt that's
activated by UV light which there's none
inside of here but I assure you it's
very cool
trust us yep I'm blaming the Sun for
being hot that is kind of a good line to
be honest
it's totally irrelevant to what he was
talking about but it is funny here's
what it looks like with the Glorious sun
shining whoa I know it
how does he do that I don't know how
they do it man think there's like
uranium in it
not the shirt oh how does he do that
Ghost Rider oh he sold his soul oh how
does he set his head on fire he he sold
a soul to the devil yeah but he's a good
guy
well no here that's a bad call
right he appears to be dead
it would seem that way but he he also
does speak it's generally the dead don't
die dude okay Dan what are you what
happened I'm just trying Laura and [__]
all of a sudden now you don't know how
skeletons work I don't know anything
about the Marvel Universe please
Dan is jealous of me
yeah we have such a fun show here so
thank you to teddyfresh.com
um
as you guys saw in the title
the subreddit
has been a point of a lot of contestion
for all of us
for the most part I love the subreddit
they provide lots of good content and
laughs but at the end of the day I think
on hold we as a crew as a family would
be better off without
the subreddit it's something we've been
debating hotly back here and I have a
whole section prepared about that which
we'll get into a little bit later
but I'm going to explain why what's
funny
the way you're framing this why
well
what's wrong with how I'm framing it
dad
so we are racing our Reddit and you know
it's been well Dan
you're it's easy for you because you
know you always take like the easy
defensible route you never put yourself
out there so you don't get hate like us
people who actually exert ourselves to
take chances to express ourselves
you know what I mean that's not true
whatever and plenty of haters
kidding hey Rich Lux
that was the one that I was gonna name
so anyway again blocked me
so we're gonna talk about that later but
we actually have before we get serious a
ton of really good stuff for example
here's Benny boy
Ben Shapiro
we actually I'm pretty sure I could sue
him for this
he posted this to his Tick Tock and it
got a lot of views didn't he why could
he why would you sue him for that
because he's literally just reposting my
content
uh he he contributed he's reacting to a
clip bro have you seen this yeah no his
reaction's terrible but no no no no
that's not a guy watch this all right
watch this Dan all right we actually
don't need it what do you mean that we
don't need gravity
what if it was never invented
Sir Isaac Newton
Isaac Newton created gravity
whoever created he's like isn't this the
guy who told me to go to the no he's
like yo this guy's kind of funny though
I'm inside your walls I don't know if he
gets that you are being he stifled his
laughter when I said Isaac Newton
invented in Creative gravity
Who's laughing he might think that
you're actually asking that is the thing
I think from his perspective you're both
have no idea what you're talking about I
don't necessarily think that he knows
that you
are playing along
with Trisha but he's definitely thinking
isn't that the guy who told me to go I
hope he realized that I really hope he
realized especially since you're dressed
as James Charles Ben he knows who I am
oh yeah for sure
um this clip is pretty iconic though and
I it makes me wonder
she was playing she was being silly
right whatever it is it's the funniest
thing I've ever seen in my life like
it's really hard to tell with her I know
it's really hard no she's definitely no
yeah she
did I don't know either again I I think
she's just mistaking inventing versus
like um
Trish is not as dumb as she looks and
thanks no I don't think she's dumb I
think she's
she's
comfortable embracing her ignorance yeah
I don't know I think
I think she's this is a lean into it
moment well she's a genius then because
this [__] is so funny yeah it's really
fun yeah yeah well I do think that okay
so anyway all those times that we played
like trivia games and uh and like
remember we played are You Smarter Than
A Fifth Grader yeah she she's not as
dumb as she pretends to be
I destroyed her in that by the way if
you recall
I don't know if I do recall it going
that way this is the top comment I feel
like that too look at this top comment
so he posted this on YouTube shorts 750
thousand views top comment I would have
said a God invented it to piss off Ethan
he [__] read you dude
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's watch this uninterrupted
and then Dan you need to answer for your
crimes we actually don't need it what do
you mean that we don't need gravity
what if it was never invented
invented by who Sir Isaac Newton
Isaac Newton created gravity whoever
created gravity is someone dead but we
don't actually need it there was a time
on Earth before gravity existed yes who
who created gravity babe
weirdos saying weird things and being
wrong about them being weird
okay now you're telling me that his
commentary offered without pausing the
video for 30 seconds justifies him
reposting my viral clip you tell me what
he added to this day that makes it fair
yes
I mean this commentary is awful but no
no he did he did some analysis at the
end there he gave his interpretation of
what he just witnessed
no he literally described what happened
he's like yeah so she from his she said
funny things said you might be able to
say his facial expressions
invented by who
that's right
you see that that was pretty good it was
crazy
but we don't actually need it
um
and being wrong about them being weird
okay shut up idiot yes love please do
that love says he's gonna edit a clip of
me watching Ben watching this is not
fair use this is a lawsuit
okay
give me a [__] break how dare you
defend him
if they really wanted to piss me up they
saw what a God invented gravity then I
would add a stroke
[Music]
um
also dude Frenemies is like two years
ago so two years ago dummy
anyway here it is whatever so Dan is a
fan of Ben Shapiro we found out today
and that just goes to show you that Dan
will always take the opposite stance of
me I can't stand it that's proof in the
pudding right there
also we have huge updates coming down
the pipeline here this morning huge
updates regarding the Las Vegas UFO
story that we attempted to debunk on
Friday but I have to say new compelling
evidence has come forward
that suggests
that warrants taking a closer second
look at it
this showed up on my Tick Tock feed it's
got 300 000 likes
now
view wise we're talking about
um
two million views this is oh wait no
this isn't even the one
where's the one the one where's the one
whenever I do this I can't find it God
damn it why did you post so many times
since then
how did you post this many tick tocks
what the [__]
wow that's crazy update on UFO do you
not see it on the page
is this even the original account I just
click yeah I just clicked well it's on
this page I just clicked through to
their profile
did they post a hundred tick tocks since
they posted this oh there it is 3.9 or 8
million where is it up up on 3.8 okay
thank you Jesus Christ
dude don't post as much what the hell
like you get one hit just let it breathe
for a minute
all right here it is guys so this this
is big all right I'm excited
okay
right how do I [__] got here I'm
gonna use the keyboard uh
why is there no audio because I muted it
all right can we restart this please
this episode
it's just [__] Mulligan
let's erase the event
okay so this is a very slow down screen
recording I took and I know everybody is
trying to find the aliens in front of
these guys but I noticed something
insane and I want everybody my two
friends to watch this to take a look
down uh pay attention to two areas we're
gonna look down here on the bottom right
behind their fence and right up there
but we're gonna first start down here
because I found something crazy yes okay
so I pay attention to it I believe it's
the creepiest part of this video and I'm
gonna point out two things you need to
pay attention to right here which is the
head and if you look really close
there's actually a shiny black eye don't
laugh you will see in about a minute is
a hand that I believe is some creature
non-human crouching down yeah and that
was its eye I just pointed at and I want
you to pay attention to
would appear to be fingers running up
the fence as if it's kneeling down I see
the fingers and then there you go see
the fingers yep and I think I I go back
and forth this Interstellar being is
caressing the fence uh right in front of
them the eavesdrop I guess I don't know
why so this is funny to me for a few
reasons the dude said they're 10 feet
tall and they're out in the field now
they're like one foot tall little
gremlins and they're right at the fence
eavesdropping okay right I see the
fingers though there's uh there was more
though he was gonna this is my face uh
yeah this guy's serious though if you
just draw an alien right here it's kind
of I mean
[Music]
what's really interesting about this is
it is happening next to them and kind of
in front of them but behind a fence
right
um the other fingers are really crazy so
yeah I think I'm gonna show up one more
time and then I zoom out and I'll show
you what even words I realized this was
here yeah no I do so
oh [__] so see how many different times
are looking so what I noticed was if you
look at the top right look at the top
right right now there's actually wait I
think it's it's cropped down here it is
[__] oh god oh no did you just I did it
I think you might have just it almost
looks like no I didn't restart it okay
it's a dense shadowy figure comes into
frame
or if you're looking right if that's
just talking about fence posts if you're
looking at the top right of them yeah
there's just a shadow bro like
a shadow oh it's like a shadow creature
it has density and it's only there for
about a minute it's like a year it's the
smart creature from Milwaukee I'm just
gonna highlight it right here I was
doing the best I could almost finger on
his foot I see it
so I don't know if maybe the
whatever creature was projecting a
shadow up above it or something
um let's see there's the eye and the
hands but it also looks like there's
another aspect to it which is that
shadow that you can clearly see walking
I know everybody's looking for the alarm
for them but there's one hiding next to
them okay so this is a very sorry phone
camera on the left hold on stop it love
so that's pretty compelling stuff 3.8
million
uh I believe it this is the best version
I've seen this is insane sixteen
thousand this is insane I see it it's 3
000. I do believe they're telling the
truth people are ridiculous for thinking
we're alone in the universe that's the
big difference between being alone in
the universe and then thinking that
there's a little [__] Gremlin
caressing the fence right in front of
them because you saw a bush rub against
it like come on
guys get your get your [__] together do
you see it what's interesting is they
are friendly if they wanted to hurt that
family they would have true
that's that's uh comforting
I live near the Nevada border and
there's crazy [__] out here you can see
the lights near mountains almost every
night
hmm
yeah I wonder what alien Society 51 has
to say about this new analysis
has they dropped any new bangers I don't
know we should check can you put could
you look cam just did an enhancer whoa
so this is appears to be if you follow
the train yeah this appears to be an
alien from Alien vs Predator which is
very dangerous for us
this is a
yeah no it's not good oh this is not
good this is not good this is a big
problem for America that's a xenomorph
that's what we call xenomorph he said
it's from uh Alien versus Predator
that's actually uh the fourth fifth film
in the uh duel franchises I know it's
alien and Predator alien and Predator
that was the crossover fine chill what
the [__] it's the same aliens dude I
will say I had a sketch over it so you
you there wasn't a clear image I had to
sketch over it like he did but I just
took a little more detail with it yeah
yeah now you can see the tail here if
you look in like obviously that's a tail
and what you can really hear so it's
very sharp until it's very sharp I
believe it I choose to believe it
all I want is one HD photo you're
telling me there was an alien like
six inches from you just snap one
[__] HD photo just find me one
Gadget made of carbon [__] alienite
that's all I want
when you talk about burning the witch
yes you know the era where we used to
burn the witch yes that area never
really stopped the type of witch who was
burning changed oh
[Music]
comprehend in order to comprehend to eat
the other the omelet of knowledge you're
gonna need to break those eggshells
right thank you reach that's very
insightful and right on right on the
nose too moving on thank you to the
aliens uh we come in peace
whatever
this is awesome so you all know
uh Fox got absolutely bodied Fox news by
um Dominion
and a defamation lawsuit the biggest
defamation lawsuit payout of all time in
a settlement they settled on 780 million
dollars no no no no yes it's true I know
and so now I'm assuming as part of their
settlement anytime anybody on their
Network mentions this uh elections was
stolen they have to correct the record
so here they are Fox News
watching a trump speech and they had to
cut away to fact check him
in the middle of his speech it's just
beautiful it's just Glory it's so
beautiful watch this oh his personality
you're going to have wars you're going
to be fighting the whole world ah really
quickly here I just want to interrupt if
you did hear the former president
speaking about what he called election
fraud there that Trump and others have
filed and lost dozens of lawsuits
contesting the election processes vote
counting and the vote certification
process in States like Georgia Arizona
and Pennsylvania super comprehensive
lawsuits like a totally prepared citing
an apparently we're ready to go
military away too and back to president
trust do not sue us again the love of
God it's like how can I their viewers
don't even care about this because
they've been saying the opposite for
years
on the network
but either way it's pretty fantastic you
gotta admit that's that is that is
entertaining
yeah I love that uh one moment from
president Trump uh we have to inform you
that President Trump actually does not
weigh 180 at his last physical he was
pushing 270.
[Laughter]
he is not in the condition of an elite
athlete in fact he was close to death as
he was on his on in the hospital with
covid
thank you shout out Fox News shout out
to Dominion shout out shout out
president Trump
by the way
we talked on Friday about uh the
indictment and now the indictment
has been unsealed and the what's inside
of that thing is [__] crazy dude
um
he literally had documents about the CIA
the FBI Homeland Security like
undercover spies and
details about America's nuclear
capabilities and vulnerabilities he had
these Ultra Ultra the n-word that's a
sick [__] souvenir dude
I do the same
it's the nuclear word so then he has
them in his shower
yeah actually the United States nuclear
[__] vulnerabilities in the shower of
Mar-A-Lago
yeah uh we showed this one photo that we
were cracking up about
on Friday
this one and a layer bathroom or
whatever we didn't even notice I saw
somebody point it out later
oh you don't see my screen hold on
is that a another there you should see
it now
number two that whole shower is
completely full of that [__] that's
where he keeps the super secure stuff
behind the curtain there's a alien back
is that [__] awesome yo is that an
alien's fingers oh [__] it's caressing
the shower curtain oh dude it's opening
the boxes
it knows our secrets
anyways YouTube is showing other subs as
live but not H3 I swear YouTube doesn't
want me to watch H3 live I don't know
what that means
other channels that it subscribed to I
don't know what's good with the YouTube
notification or just it's not even
showing
that we're live now
I agree to I agree they don't want us
they don't want us to succeed out here
you know they're taking the hinges and
put it on the [__] boy's hands yep I'm
ripping them off every day Susan's gone
so what can we do
um is the crashing still happen that's
all I want to know I've seen a report of
it today yet that's good uh I just
search History podcast on my personal
account and I see our live as the first
result it says live on our channel so
okay I think it's if you follow multiple
channels that are live at the same time
it only gives you one like why wouldn't
ours be the one we are the premier live
on this whole platform okay no the
number one what else are they going to
show Who's Live um Teletubbies 24 7
reruns about the [__]
so anyway uh as I was saying and then
the really crazy part about the
indictment okay
is he he hired this new lawyer when he
first got subpoenaed for the documents
and he's like what if we just don't give
them the documents we don't answer the
subpoena which is illegal
and then the lawyer's like no I can't do
that that's illegal I have to give them
the documents
and then
the lawyer was coming to collect the
documents to return it to the government
and Trump took it out before the lawyer
could get to them and put them somewhere
else
and now and so also Trump told his
lawyer to go into his hotel room and
destroy the really bad ones
he goes just pluck him out he goes just
pluck out the really bad ones it's all
in the indictment you can read it it's
incredible and so they were here's the
best part awesome they were able to
um interrogate
his attorney usually you can't do that
because of attorney-client privilege but
because he used his attorney
to
Consulting and to help facilitate
committing a crime
they're able to pierce the
attorney-client privilege under a
judge's order and then the the [__]
lawyer flipped on him
and sang like a canary dude
sing like a canary
his own [__] lawyer dude it's so
awesome and the other lawyers just quit
yeah it's looking I don't know and then
when that when the FBI raided
so the lawyer who was misled by trouble
is like here's 24 documents and then
when the FBI they're like that's
[__] FBI rated and found a hundred
another hundred classified documents in
his shower and [__]
that's awesome
somebody said is my eye okay what's
wrong with my eye are you okay is your
eye okay
there's something wrong with my eye
so okay I am seeing
what people are talking about now
um and this is Maybe
I'll make a note I should send a note to
your YouTube rep or whatever
yeah oh it just flipped weird it also
just crashed we're getting crashes wait
what what is the issue Dan I'm confused
it's not so like when you when I go to
my sub tab it shows all of the channels
that you're subscribed to with a little
blue dot next to them I think if there's
new content but it's a red dot if
they're live currently and I see other
subs of mine red
but ours is blue until a second ago
where all of a sudden it finally flipped
red maybe just takes a minute I mean
you're out of control we've been live
for 30 minutes so
um can we let's tweet at [__] YouTube
again it's buggy as [__] dude okay hold
on we're doing this again because I'm so
sick
of this crashing [__] here's the tweet
in question I'm gonna hit him again
Apple too or something all right well
it's YouTube's gotta tweet Apple
what Tim Cook well I'm on an Android
phone I'm using the YouTube app on
Android and it also wasn't showing us
live so
okay and uh I saw some uh I saw a lot of
people saying they didn't get a
notification either today please please
please
help fix this bug
all right guys go do your thing send
screenshots tell them everything
sick of this [__]
please
so no notifications were crashing and
also on the sub page it doesn't show the
Red Dot awesome
let's call an audible [__] the whole
destroying the subreddit angle let's
just delete the YouTube channel today
we're deleting our YouTube channel
protest
we still have 32 000 That's The Power of
family really
ride together die together that is
powerful send out yeah
we need to send out like Messengers all
of you like Paul Revere style leave your
homes let everyone know uh-huh we're
live
all right so anyway we were talking so
anyway the Trump indictment is is
incredible I mean he's so [__]
um we'll see well I'm eternally
skeptical people are starting to turn on
Bill Barr although I know that they have
a conflict his former Attorney General
went on Fox News and was like he is
[__] yeah everyone he's ever worked
with previously hates him and thinks
that he's [__]
um which does say a lot but I don't know
I'm just I'm cynical there it is okay
thank you we won't talk about too much
about Trump here today we'll save that
for Thursday if there is a Thursday show
we'll find out because Hassan's going to
Japan I had a beat off uh another one
here we have a drill sergeant hmm
drill sergeant uh this is the frame
why is it geez this is like a private
this isn't actually military this is
like
stupid wait why they're doing this for
fun this man's honest what the [__]
that is not hard bro you can't wheel in
on a one wheelie
with a cigar you're confused man the
only way you're gonna be better
what's up you can't walk
you're going like 50 Feet max
imum
people pay to do this
yeah so it's like one of those extreme
like
boot camp workout
programs I'm paying you
to watch me crawl along a train track
I'm calling your back awesome yeah I
like to because I wonder how much it is
man
clearly it's pretty this guy's doing
pretty good because I don't know if you
guys noticed but
he's kind of riding pretty fat here get
your [__] ass up and work that one
wheeler doesn't look cheap so okay shout
out to the Army we love the Army folks
it's so cool people who aren't even in
it paid to pretend they are
not great
1800 for that thing okay so he's bawling
I believe so unless they're cheaper yeah
oh yeah they go up to like uh 2200 now
is that something that you would buy a b
or or yeah they they closed down boosted
board which is very sad boosted board
shut down yeah shut down during the
pandemic which sucks because now all of
us who have booster boards we're kind of
stuck like we're stuck with uh
with no one to help us there's like
third party people that will help and
there's like a subreddit of people but
they went out of business yeah what the
heck I thought they were like killing it
yeah they were like top of the game but
then they started like investing in a uh
like a scooter
um some scooters that combined with
covet I think is what Screwed them over
I find it fun and companies it's like
where everything is great we're perfect
we're crushing it everybody loves us but
because of you know we have it's always
bigger better more money we're gonna
we're gonna risk our whole [__]
company on a scooter and then when it
doesn't succeed we literally go bankrupt
it's wild man I love that yeah they used
to call themselves The the Lamborghini
of uh Escape I don't know they call them
that but I know online a lot of people
refer to them as a Lamborghini of
electric skateboards
yeah yeah he was like their guy yeah he
was now they're the pinto of uh
skateboarding
which is not the thing you want to be
let's see oh oh my God you guys are
gonna love this so so much
Stephen Crowder made Brian callan's
mother cry
now we talked about this what a sentence
and this is this is 100 real
this is uh Stephen Crowder posted this
to Twitter check this and I think we
watched it before but here it is
[Music]
that's Brian Callan alpha male
red pill to [__]
it's just acting bro
they're just acting it's all Crowder
tweet so now the bit did this is
interesting
the bit didn't work they never posted it
but Crowder posted this online
nobody would have seen it otherwise and
it humiliated Brian actually I know we
joked about it but apparently he was
getting burned by all of his friends
by tons of people online and even to the
point where his mom called him and he
says this willingly
this is this is equivalent to going and
saying I hugged the girl and [__] my
pants why he's admitting to this
is stunning but here it is
[__] sandwich so here he is uh with
his other fantastic project uh with uh
the Schwab the ear swab Brendan yeah
here it's talking about it looks like
you're gonna take the SATs right my mom
called me very upset she said there's a
video that says Stephen Crowder's been
humiliating you and put you in a cow
suit and I said Mom and I created that
video he never I know I said he's never
humiliated me we get along very well if
anything it's the opposite and I put
myself in that cow suit and then she
went she goes why and I go I thought it
would be funny I like to push the um
dude that's my favorite it goes I'm
pushing the envelope
this guy this guy's a comedian bro he's
pushing the envelope high level stuff
this is high high level yo mom I'm
pushing the envelope right here y'all
come on sometimes comedians got to take
chances mom yeah
and sometimes you miss so for whoever
made that brilliant video I didn't see
it but apparently you clipped it so it
looks and I sent it to the group chat oh
you did yeah yeah and we've all made fun
of you okay well so they made somebody
made the video clipped it up you made my
mom cry you son of a [__] good video
though congratulations
I haven't seen that video Yeah somebody
made me have an amazing video but it's
just like Brian Callum is being
humiliated yeah but it but it I guess
they clipped it in such a way my poor
mother you son of a [__]
you still did that
that's your video so many layers
that he's admitting to this
yikes
like some [__] freak out there made
it look like I was in a cow suit getting
whipped by the guy behind me that's so
[__] up so the commentary Channel how
the reason I even found this clip is I
was watching I think the commentary
Channel he's mad at is this guy too lazy
to try
and I was watching his video last night
and it is a funny Channel as most common
YouTube commentary channels go he
probably has at least 20 videos uh
talking about me being whatever but I
like this channel I'm not I you know I
mean I'm not even gonna hate uh he's
like me he's like a men's version of T
channel it's kind of Epic I love I get
filled in on lots of stuff he talks
about like Joe Rogan drama it's it's
really good I actually learned a lot
from it actually I'm gonna give him a
plug I think his channel is good too
lazy to try I love his icon too it's
just Costanza with chips on him
yeah
um dude I I was learning so much last
night
um
okay I watched this problem what about
the Schwab lore Schwab lore Brian he did
apology to Brian callan's mom that was
funny I didn't know about this comedian
that lied about being in 9 11 it was
[__] crazy
um here's one about me Ethan Klein's
Fallout with Jordan Peterson which I'm I
don't watch videos about myself uh
anymore to preserve my sanity
but I love getting all this uh
this alphalore it's awesome
which one I watched um
whatever
it's a good channel to be honest
but um
we doing a slow clap
but yeah I thought it was I thought this
whole thing was so good dude you're a
genius son of a [__] my mother's 82.
81. hey you can do what you're told
though right
right
it's like Michael Chandler Connor and
and Carter wants me into account you do
what you're told have you seen that oh
he goes oh were we doing this this and
he goes I would like to do this and kind
of looks up and they're like being
pretty cordial and kind of like saying
this you'll do what you're told and you
know oh that's you right
yeah and then you can get on plane fly
to Dallas yeah it's awesome I love it
um so Brian's mom is crying uh because
he this is the this is where his career
has gone after all these years
you know and now he's just Crowder's
little [__] Whipping Boy literally
his whipping boys
yeah and Brian Collins a giant piece of
[__] he's one of the guys that called
one of the main instigators of bowling
Bobby Lee during that whole thing he
also has some pretty nasty allegations
against him I believe allegedly
sorry about your mother's owning you for
being equipped
that's probably why she was crying
you know he looked like he was enjoying
it just a little too much
so shout out to Brian callan's mom she
had that ripe old age of 82 hopefully uh
he doesn't bring any more too much
stress into her life
thank you
thank you very much
um okay
more top of the show Shenanigans okay
this is potentially
the most [__] crazy thing
and I know this is gonna sound
hyperbolic
but this is maybe the craziest Tick Tock
I've ever seen
and we've seen a dude [__] a peanut
butter this is up there I mean this is
in the running it's stunning yeah
so here it is it's almost like warn
people like it's like so disturbing well
I think to me it's funny
he wants it to be disturbing
obviously his kid is I mean it's funny
that he's doing something so disturbing
like I I found it funny too I don't know
if you're if you're sensitive at all his
kid is fine the kid's fine he didn't
actually drown no no children were
harmed in the making of this video Let's
just say that
although it looks like it at times it's
so nuts why did he make this can is this
still on Tick Tock I'm curious about the
reception of it there but anyway here
let's enjoy this
never leave a child unintended in a pool
right
yeah
[Music]
uh oh
yeah actually this is really depressing
and sad I mean I have kids that age it's
[__]
oh my God man why would he do that with
his own child the shot it's just [__]
nuts your own child you're gonna pretend
that they drowned stop buddy stay still
stay still stay still just stay still
for a while don't move your face don't
move don't worry don't breathe don't
breathe oh damn
[Music]
heartbroken heartbreak emoji
now this this guy oh my God he's coming
for the Academy Award
yeah
one of the top comments is put them in
rice
oh true
[Laughter]
now this is
oh there's certain points where it's
like is this a joke when he's like
scrambling to go over the slide
dude this is insane why would you even
pretend to do that like I'm sorry look
how deep he is
your kid is scared man that's so crazy
22 million views on tick tock
wait okay okay but I shared this too so
I wonder yeah no the comments are all
pretty negative it's still up I sent the
link okay so he crushed it in a sense
I'm sorry but I feel this is traumatic
for his child
also why is he holding the kickboard
he's holding the kickboard against his
body why
um maybe to hide his legs from moving oh
you think so or yeah there's no reason
he should be holding the kickboard
against his boss it's a good observation
I'm not really sure that would be for
kick because his legs aren't limp I
guess he's trying to sell it Jesus
also does he not know um
CPR CPR or like yeah like a meme
do mouth to mouth do anything to try
don't you're Don't Panic don't just say
goodbye this isn't what you do yeah take
them out and go to mount the mouth man
try to resuscitate brother otherwise it
just looks like a hit job
oh my God
yeah here we go are you shaking I'm
sorry he's selling it too much look at
this look how his head shakes
you see that Jesus
you by the way your kid is he's not dead
right
we're we're all laughing this this
wasn't a stage video you gotta see the
head shaking
the head gyrating is something
yeah look at this look at that
Jesus
oh the slo-mo and he's holding his son's
head still while he's doing this
he better bought him ice cream or
something
put it in a
in a solid movie Oscar that is yeah
specifically that's raw this is Oscar
bait
I feel that this could be a potentially
good uh Avatar logo for him new profile
picture like his new Niche also it's
pride month friendly with the rainbow
and back
which is nice yeah
yeah your phone does uh
those automatic reels where it puts yeah
they're like a compilation he like gets
one yeah
[Laughter]
actually speaking of that
um
my sister-in-law sent us a
auto-generated video of Theodore she has
a bunch of like videos of him that Apple
did with like AI or machine learning
whatever and it was
insane like it was really good it was so
good and I was it's creepy and actually
I mean it was really good but also kind
of creepy huh interesting but it was it
was very uh it was very beautiful I mean
the shots and everything and you really
see him like aging hmm I was like wow
that was nice so I'm kind of I'm kind of
Twisted on it what was creepy about it
because like
they know what my kid looks like
well that aspect I guess exists
regardless of the edit that like they
went in the phone or they this whatever
went in the phone right it can detect
looked at all of our videos and I was
like here's their skid
Theodore Klein who lives at this address
but I don't know they know everything
about us but it was really cool so you
know
it is amazing like especially when I'm
trying to find a photo you could search
like anything you could search the color
green you could search a name a number
and any photo that's right it's in there
that I've used for myself
so I guess it it is very useful you know
what I mean but
it's a little creepy I guess
I'll get over it
my kid didn't drown
yeah no it would have been worse
could have been a lot worse
off comment
put it in rice that's awesome
what the hell
um okay interesting hello
yeah I don't think maybe maybe there's
one person who's like oh [__] maybe I
shouldn't leave my child unattended in a
pool
they're like huh
yeah
true maybe he did save someone even if
it gets through to one that's a win
right yeah and they provided us a lot of
humor so that well the net positive for
Humanity I'd say that's a huge win dude
yeah used to come up and reach in the
pool kids jumping on my lap pulling my
hairs in the pool oh my God what about
kids jumping on my lap he has more of
these find my beautiful daughter dead
oh God wait you're right here this one
has 600 000 grieving the loss of my
daughter okay bro you need to stop role
playing I mean you need to stop
imagining your kids dying it's [__]
strange some Gary fee [__] he took
garyvee different perspectives
genuine sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face
what Olivia this man needs to go to like
some sort of course it seems like he has
a passion for this and he's putting it
in the wrong places right improv class
my dude I would say I would say maybe
like Groundlings maybe like Second City
yeah man you got talent You Got Talent
you gotta Channel it okay you've got
yeah now this is weird if you read the
description grieving the loss of my
daughter hashtag grief grief Journey
grief from us people think that this is
real and the comments are I'm sorry for
your loss oh no so sorry for your loss
he's presenting this as if it's real and
people are treating it as such let's
watch
thank you
I don't know about you but the death of
a child is really encapsulated by the
breaking heart emoji yeah that really
where is he in the woods that has um
security guards holding them back from
his dead daughter
let's watch what what is the scenario
here let's see
[Laughter]
sorry for your loss
what is wrong with you man
why is this a hobby of pretending your
kids died
sorry
she what was like a victim of a violent
crime under the bridge I mean what the
[__] are we doing here oh my God that
shot was really stunning he's just
running
it's like a dream sequence he's just
I have one that we might not be able to
show maybe even if you could switch off
for a sec oh wait you can't come to this
bridge security is stopping you do not
come under this bridge
do not come just running around no this
is a private Bridge can't come here all
right dude you gotta stop this really
stop it
my deepest condolences I can't watch
this it's breaking my heart
here's a here's a potentially another
good profile picture for him
me too I feel your pain my son was
killed in the woods one month ago and
I'm going insane still can't believe it
happened he was only 19.
that's just
that's just not fair that if that's true
and you have to watch this video
this guy's parodying your [__] pain
all right show me the other one I love
this guy
I sent him were you worried that it was
a
two [__] up this one we're gonna watch
now this one yeah I mean I guess you
could show her so don't show it at first
Ian let me see I'll read it my therapist
just told me people who suffered
impression anxiety tend to re-watch the
same TV show all over again because they
already know what is going to happen
next therefore it creates a sense of
safety comfort and that's the reason
they keep watching them it's him with
his head submerged
wait what is okay you can show this it's
fine he's just screaming underwater I
don't I don't get the
not getting the connection wait
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's wrong with watching the same show
because you like it man
this is not that bad it's just fine
so this is what you find on Tick Tock I
don't know above that I sent his thank
you for 700k Zach is cracking me up
today holy [__] here he's just
cosplaying here's another one here he is
cosplaying every parent's worst
nightmare
#uh parents of tick tock daddy's boy
missing
oh God give me back my son what like a
ransom let's see he's doing like a taken
give me the audio
[Music]
dude why are you using your beautiful
son
oh my God man what is wrong with you why
are you doing this
all of his videos about his kids dying
he said well he has one of his wife
dying too well this one that seems to be
a kidnap scenario right
I I can't tell
I guess missing yeah because he was
screaming give me back my son well
[__] go don't let him wander off like
that
oh no oh the bad guys oh my God he's
playing two parts in this one not bad
guys
this last one I found he looks like
[__] the bubbles
dude there's gotta be a wetter better
outlet for your
Creative Energy yeah there's gotta be
[Music]
it's just gotta be
I have your son
dude please after this look at the last
one I sent he literally looks like
Smeagol arguing with himself
sounds good to me
here's this new profile picture by the
way
very very good stuff
that one is from when he lost his wife
okay oh this guy is really a lot of
tragedy in this case
yeah one kid drowned he had another
kidnapped he had one other his daughter
under a bridge I guess
okay uh cheating wife is confronted by
husband dude stop oh she cheated on too
and then she died look how [__] up his
face look I'm telling you that looks
like
don't worry
I can't be bullied you're not worth the
trouble it would take to hit you dude
what what you're not worth the trouble
it would take to hit you
right okay let's not let's not what
would make it worth the trouble to hit
her let's not even go down that road if
you're gonna write this in script down
film it don't don't say that
I would beat the [__] out of you
but it's kind of a hassle it's but it
frankly uh
I have work tomorrow
I don't want the music
you're not worth the powder it would
take to blow you up oh you are empty
empty shell of a woman
I mean what the hell are you doing if
you hate me so much
what the hell are you even married to me
what the hell are you doing carrying my
child oh and you didn't get rid of it
when you had the choice because listen
to me
I've got news for you
I wish to God that you had oh
voice but it came out more jar jar so
how is him saying I wish the arch child
was never born a diss at her
yo dude you need you bro what the [__]
every video is him fantasizing about his
wife or his kids dying or being murdered
or kidnapped
this is um this is what the murder porn
guy was like before I found God exactly
exactly he needs to find God he says
he's an actor bringing awareness
bringing awareness that somebody needs
to intervene in your family life
it's like um it's like Darman but just
way more [__] grotesque and dark
nurse loses patience
[Laughter]
nurse loses face oh my god did he buy
that costume hashtag
NHS NHS nurse hashtag Gray's Anatomy
let me see let me see if we can hear
this one stop putting Music Man
he's really good at like getting his
mouth all yeah mucused out he loves to
spit this kind of his move
I have a surgeon damn it tick tock that
works so well with that scream you use
Zach
Zach can you hit with the Keem scream
I have a job for you Cam
what's up make a compilation of every
time this guy screams like this
where it's like it's all spitty and [__]
he does it in every video
I want that oh yeah
I know that it might take a while but
you want a video of it or or image no a
video okay yeah oh oh yeah I think that
would be something worth worth putting
into
so there we go
love him
actually speaking of garyvee who uh
probably
inspired this guy to make these videos
from the garyvee video here
ah garyvee we all have different paths
big shout out to all the great students
I respect those skills and huge shout
out to all of us that learn different
and had different skills and figured out
[__] another way
have the best weekend so here he's
telling people not to do homework and
people stop listening to garyvee yet
I think so because this is from two days
ago it has 8 800 likes so that's kind of
falling off
well let's see what uh wise uh advice is
about to hop on my plane missing class
to go to vcon means I'm doing five hours
of homework on the plane see you soon I
quote retweet it homework life this
means he will do five more hours of
homework than I did in my entire High
School career combined I always laughed
that people like don't believe that you
never did homework Gary forget about
homework never study I don't care it
does I don't I have I don't I believe
you why would I not people don't believe
this when I tell them
I used to go late to school
paper test I never opened a book that
didn't give you anxiety for what
worrying about something that I knew
nothing oh my God you are so
embarrassing dude how old is he
he is now put that phone down
47. he's 47 he's like yeah I knew school
is [__] when I was in high school I
was cool and I got it back then I'm like
the other idiot students
you know he's gonna believe him as that
kid I knew I was destined to make
hundreds of Millions nfts
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [__] tonight okay he didn't
go that far
[Music]
that's one of the best sound drops ever
different perspectives yeah
graduate I basically rolled the dice
listened in class for a couple grades
got
listened because I loved history so I
got bees and then they just passed me
through because I basically like halfway
through freshman year high school was
like I'm gonna stay back and then I kind
of got like whiff of like the school was
going for like good verification like
Blue Ribbon or something and I was like
what does that mean that means they want
everybody to pass and I'm like see ya
some kids at the airport he goes about
to hop on my plane missing
awesome
school is important guys especially in
high school he's not even like college
he's like no high school is [__]
don't do your homework and that kid
these are younger than high school too
to be honest I know he said high school
but the kid in the photo looked even
younger than that dude
high school is good high school is
important we like high school college we
can debate
yeah I used to [__] around in middle
school I didn't give a [__] about that
stuff arithmetic is for for accountants
and idiots I paid people to do
arithmetic for me
garyvee the ever insightful
whatever happened to be friends can we
pull that up and see what they're
trading for
because last time we checked his little
Doodles were selling for like hundreds
of thousands
um
you keep saying no the world keeps
saying yes the answer to finding next
big thing is being a yes person versus a
no person the next big thing is obvious
to a lot of people here it's called
artificial intelligence do you know how
many people in this entire hall right
now dismisses as bad do you know how
many people are using uh chat gbt to do
strip Drop Shipping
do you know Chachi Boutique can
translate and automatically write books
that you can put up on Amazon and sell
the future is AI
oh it's gonna take people's jobs away so
is the tractor we were all doing farm
jobs and then a tractor was invented and
that took people's jobs away they found
different jobs most people are no people
no to tick tock no to chat no to VR no
he's right but in a sense chat GPT or
programs like it
stand to steal everybody's job at the
same time not just like farmers and [__]
that's a little more serious than that
go to AR they fear new things people
just I don't know who's talking about
yes yes such a goofball man also he made
out with his dad I don't know if you
guys remember that
yo no not the V friends
now I told you guys
that this v-friends restaurant he was
gonna open would never be made
and I stand by that what's up with the V
friends restaurant he was going to open
a social club
and you had to own a v-friend to get
into this restaurant
oh [__] this is so funny
so the average price is down to two and
a half
eth this is sales for you
wait what sales volume well here's his
average price
and here it says volume so how am I
supposed to decode that
no it makes sense it makes sense yeah
she's the sale wait it doesn't make
sense does it track volume or price
it's a bit confusing both lines mean
oh there's two lines yeah there's gray
and blue I guess oh I think no I think
it's just the line the line is a
it's a graphing the the the bottom one
it's the same thing average price is
below two eth and earlier this year was
18 so it's like dude I try to tell
people nobody listens to me he goes the
world says yes yes I'm saying dude you
need to say no no no to Gary V more
because that guy made like a hundred
million dollars selling you morons
doodles
what the [__]
did what the [__]
you all seen this [__]
people paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars just earlier this year yeah
earlier this year
for this
what the [__] did I say he makes 10 of
all sales yeah yeah every time there's a
sale it's [__] insane
I think he probably made more than 100
Mil
look at this
look at this and then realize what
you've done
you [__] you are the biggest sucker
in the world
wow
and garyvee is not a good guy he doesn't
care about your success he cares about
his success
he's like Andrew Tate minus the essay
and the trafficking because like it's
the same thing the husband well hold on
I have a point the Hustler University
it's not about helping it's about making
money for him only I mean every
self-help person is the same sure that
yeah I feel like
well I said minus the essay in
trafficking okay yeah
you know
I'm gonna put that on Gary although he
he he's committed to his father
wait this is the [__] restaurant it's
a pop-up
come see us today at V friends pop-up
Cafe we're excited to give our community
a place to come together enjoy good food
and drinks dude this looks like [__]
this is real what the [__] time 9 A.M to
9 p.m and yes the V friends bus will be
here oh looks like a kindergarten the
kitty friend's Boss look at the
engagement 1 600 likes you guys got
played dude
yo is this the V friends bus
I want to see the Veep friends bus hold
on I think I might have found it dude
you guys I hope that whoever bought
these now realizes
wait it's just a it's just a mock-up
that's the Box do we have a final that's
the Bang Bus this one this one
it's a pop-up bus he didn't mean just
the drawing of it is here right no okay
here Olivia found the
there it is Yo he's putting his he's
putting his money where his mouth is
this is not what the V friends look like
at all this is that's actually better
it's way way but also horrible
I mean I'm not saying it's great but
it's infinitely better than the V
friends
why didn't he put the V friends all over
the side of the bus you know he didn't
think that that would be a good life not
very confident in the art
just put his Doodles all over it
so this guy made over 100 million
dollars potentially
and he spent
yeah
he painted a bus and he opened a shitty
pop-up Cafe that's like a shuttle it's
an airport shuttle
holy [__] dude
oh man I love checking in on garyvee
different perspectives people really
respect him huh
yep I get why everybody look at your
phone right now
keep going different perspectives play
the whole thing
look at your phone right now
now put that phone down different
perspectives oh wow
no yeah this is RV friend that we made
exclusive really good yeah this is a
handstand or some weird position and
look at it again I think it's it's still
listed if someone wants to buy it still
up I think so nobody bought it huh
I mean [__] what's this selling for two
eth will do it for two eighth was that
like at this 3 000 or something maybe 3
600. I don't know I do want to put out
that we I think if we can accept that we
single-handedly put this image in the
internet
um lore base show it again we did this
right I wasn't aware of anybody
mentioning it before as far as I know
that was my friend Jackson's find it
Adult Swim so yeah drop that to the
table
and it's now part of the ethos
actually [__] garyvee has a new
representative on V fronts this might
move change things around a little bit
oh POV you are confronting garyvee for
using your son's college fund to buy
v-frame
okay I like this angle this is good
that's good
son I I know it's going to pay off
we just have to hold strong Diamond hand
son
he did Diamond hands these meme friends
it's gonna work out I know it
oh [__] man that's funny
yeah Jimmy Lee a friend of the show
looking forward to his stand-up set
the 23rd me too he's running out of
memes
what that's what this new post says
his new story no no no he says I'm
running out of memes nudes start
tomorrow
[Music]
you're into that
wait I think that this would be so great
for him yeah yeah Jamie Lee only fans
it'll give him an outlet creatively you
know yeah they're all different flavors
I wonder if his pubes have a similar
hairline
Maybe by naked he just means he's not
gonna put the artificial hairline on
vulnerable tomorrow do people spray
hairlines on their balls
all different flavors I think that could
be interesting for him
that can be interesting hold it oh man
this is so what was this the Kings had a
birthday celebration and this this just
goes to show you what [__] goals
these guys are
apparently it was real hot in England
and King Charles
whoever that is it's King sausage
fingers
had a parade in his honor
and his his uh loyal soldiers are
literally dropping dead of heat stroke
qualities the British army has suffered
since World War II you still going on
the floor take a look at this and these
guys are just like oh you can play the
music I think this one's fine
the music's good here
yo
bro they're straight up tap dancing on
this man's corpse
and then so here comes the medics
now here's where it gets really
interesting if you look in the back
they're wailing someone else off they're
dropping like flies out there
[Music]
King Charles man it's not that important
holy [__]
there's more than one person dropping
out
a brutal war that day my friends we lost
a lot of good men
why do the good always Die Young poor
guy
we honored King we honored King Charles
that day
but we lost a lot of good men
we stormed the Palace of uh first uh
what's it called their palace Buckingham
Buckingham
Buckingham Palace was never the same
blood was spilled on the battlefield
sweat not actually no sweat they were
dehydrated had teeth stroke
the corpses were bone dry
so yeah they were hitting uh like the
mid 80s in uh in London this week we're
dying from mid 80s weather
well they're not used to it well this I
know that I know that's like average for
the summer uh or fall here but man I
walked around in a full Chewbacca outfit
when I was like 100 degrees at my
brother's wedding I mean what they're
wearing isn't that far away from a
Chewbacca outfit it does look hot as
hell
unimportant announcement Buckingham
Palace has announced the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II
and now I now play Lizzy in a box over
this
whoo
King Charles
uh we kid the royalty we love the
royalty folks
I don't think King Charles is gonna last
very long
just looking at him
he doesn't look particularly healthy but
you would have said the same about the
queen she lived for [__] centuries so
no but like well how old is King Charles
because the queen I mean yeah she looks
sick but she's like 120. he's 74.
74 I mean that's pretty ripe
I give them 10 years Max with those
fingers no man Arnold Schwarzenegger's
uh he's 75. Arnold looks good yeah yo
you know he went vegan he's like all
about vegan now oh is he actually didn't
know that good for him I just watched
his documentary on Netflix it's really
good he's been vegan for a while and he
looks fantastic he preaches by the vegan
diet um it's pretty cool pretty
interesting guy he's the daddy I like
Arnold he's a real interesting guy
um yeah
why do you cough like that because he's
Republican no I'm kidding also remember
it I mean that crazy story when uh he
had like the secret baby that is pretty
[__] crazy
with uh someone who worked in his house
I think that's a Vibe yeah that's a Vibe
I didn't know his wife was a Kennedy oh
yeah dude oh yeah he is he's married he
got
he got that like Alexander Hamilton
wedding yeah that political wedding you
know what I mean I know what you mean
he married up for sure
good for him
yeah King sausage fingers he's going to
croak within 10 years absolutely
guaranteed he's gonna be in a box right
next to his Dear Mama
get down
uh anyway we honor the king
and um
wishing many years
of happy living
uh
you know I'm trying to get inspired for
ideas for our live shows we're trying to
go all out as we sell bigger venues and
have a bigger budget tell me what you
guys think of this pink was inspiring me
I'm gay
is that pink actually actually I'm not
um
what was that awesome we've watched that
the crowd erupts in like applause we
watched it recently
actually I'm not gay it's just so odd
actually I'm not
it's just so odd here's the video
why did she do that I'm gay
[Applause]
actually I'm not why
why did you do that you've never heard
of a goof you never heard of a prank I
think she was trying to say that her
sexuality doesn't matter that is yeah
I'm not
it's weird actually I'm not I'm gay
actually I'm not actually I'm not okay
so anyway tell me what you guys think
about this if this is a good idea for me
I don't know if this is going to work on
my body type but we could practice I
don't know here she is at her show
like I did
like a rag doll dude
I said It reminds me of a super smash
elimination
are you scared
look at her asking absolutely incredible
dude you sent this yesterday I didn't
watch it until later in the evening and
I was I was crying I was laughing I'm
not so [__] good
it's pretty impressive I guess no for
sure but I'm pretty sure
ragdolling like that is like what you're
supposed to do
but it just looks so [__] funny she's
like super well-trained in Circus like
silks and stuff she does at her shows
okay yeah you know what she looks like
she's a boss you know when like a skier
or snowboarder just ragdolls down the
Mountainside exactly this is what she's
doing in the air it's fantastic oh miss
you look at that foreign
[Music]
I think people are even confused I don't
know how impressive it was they're just
like what the [__] I wish we could play
the sound too because it's so funny
because it's a concert it's like the
music's still going and it's just like
well the singer just disappeared up into
the Raptors she's in the middle of
singing her song So What yeah
she was still singing as she was doing
those flips too yeah you hear it a
little bit it just takes her out to the
parking lot so she could beat the
traffic out
oh it's like a Simpsons gang
oh that's so fantastic so I don't know
you think this should that looks like a
pretty serious rig to catapult her all
the way to the side yeah
yeah and it can go wrong
um those are so dangerous well take a
look at the next Link in the dock I
don't think you saw this you you put a
finger in one of those boy you're in big
trouble oh she failed on The Wire oh no
not pink
oh this is the same uh oh
wait what is happening why are they
holding on to it oh my God
that's scary
was that you should watch it with sound
is that backup dancer really trying too
so there's 10 with this like insane
bungee I guess I probably panicked
um yeah she the she's doing the arm
cross thing which I'm pretty sure is the
sign to the uh stunt coordinator or
whatever to not go
and uh somebody doesn't get the memo
that's fantastic okay it looks like
they're the backup dancer is supposed to
connect it yeah like something isn't too
much urgent on this one on the left yeah
oh
[Applause]
she said she says go she says go
but she was saying no I I it seems to me
that the tension I don't think they
launched her it was just the tension
yeah hold her to the side
I think that you would have a better
method than just having the honeybees
come and connected
that's honestly could have been worse
those that [__] scares me it would cut
off your finger when yeah no serious
rigging
how dare you giggle like that
foreign
actually I'm not oh okay clears it up
for us thank you
okay
the way she was still singing while
swinging reminding me of Fergie doing
the cartwheels and saying wait what
she's singing is she doing that yeah
for today
8 54 a.m
that is very early man
we probably shouldn't watch anymore yeah
thank you Fergie they're very impressed
with these performers go
um designer trying to revolutionize
airplane seating finally
I'm sick of the way the airplane seats
are arranged it's just not right it's on
democratic
it's dehumanizing
what do we have here
welcome to a new era of flying
sustainably uncomfortably
okay I'm intrigued
economy seat right lots of leg room he
looks comfortable I like it it's giving
gaming chair
[Music]
okay he's elevated Studio stadium
seating
so you can always get a front row seat
at the plane uh catapulting to earth
right
okay
this is where we have a problem wait
you tricked me I said more humanizing
not less this is like a
can I say this
oh no
where are you going with this
[Music]
um
yeah
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and say yeah
uh yeah I just wanted to check see now
it's kind of it's silly yeah I got
approval so I was just saying it reminds
me of like a slave ship how they
stacking people on top of each other
yeah yeah no it it is kind of like that
I'm not trying to travel like this how
much this ticket gonna be is it going to
be like 10 bucks
definitely not probably the same price
bro don't sit there like you're all
sleeping peacefully this is a [__]
Abomination give me two hundred dollars
well indeed like
this is unreal the the angle of the high
seat
the bottom of the high seat being
perfectly head level with your face how
do you even get out oh wow you're gonna
fart in there yeah bro oh yeah it's like
you're right there you're literally
here's the funny part packed in with the
high seams that are gonna cost more
yeah probably and you're gonna it'll be
less to catch farts in your face for
nine hours
[Laughter]
oh man
don't sit there and smile at me like you
[__] think this is good for the world
how dare you
haven't we been through a goddamn enough
on airplanes and you want to take more
yeah cover it up that's it
don't ever show that to anybody
be ashamed of yourself
air strikes welcome to a new era of
flying sustainably and comfortably as it
should be what the [__] are you saying
so here's the thing
my biggest
complaint flying on an airplane is that
is the leg room right because they've
squeezed it down so
so much and like I'm not even that tall
but
my legs get so cramped sitting in an
airplane for hours and I can only
imagine anybody that's like six three or
higher like how could you you would have
to fly first class like it's impossible
to even fit in there so this this gives
everybody way more leg room
but how so go back and look at the
pictures you can see
what do you mean more legroom because
the the height if you're on the bottom
because the high seat is elevated it's
not look at his legs all the way out
that is not a good trade-off
it is a trade-off though I'm pointing
out what the trade-off is you I I I it's
I think it's still tighter there's
they're packing what do they mean more
eco-friendly what do they mean because
you're sucking in the fart instead of
letting the atmosphere I think just
because you can pack more people onto a
plane your bodies will act as a
decarbonizing the air as you suck in
other passengers fart
laughs
there's got to be a height limit though
because it's like let's be real
first up the top level just the right
height no bucket is required couple has
no room like though
designed the Prototype with two ladder
type steps for travelers to use access
to the top level it's a little
precarious but once I'm up there the
seat feels roomy and comfortable and
there's plenty of room for stretching
out my legs the Prototype seats don't
move but they're each set up in a
different position to indicate how they
were reclined
[Music]
awesome
[__] awesome
oh yeah I like AB solution that he just
sent
I thought the future was supposed to be
like
better than that
you know they're like let's what if as
technology uh advances we just shrink
the space you get in an airplane
was it uh I think it's in the Fifth
Element
everybody just has like these lay down
pods and then they just like it's good
and then they uh I think they like they
go to sleep they go to sleep they like
pump everybody full of gas I'd honestly
do that like just put me in the Pod
knock me out and wake me up when we get
there like that sounds great well they
were traveling to like Mars or something
it was like yeah they were going to
another planet or whatever but I always
thought it was presumptuous to put them
out
like maybe you want to play a mobile
game
the whole time no three days just a race
what about get some work done
let you have work to do on the show Dan
hell no
chat gbt does my entire job
[__] you I've automated that [__] okay
so there we go so let's talk about
Reddit now
although I do have to go to the bathroom
first
once you do that I could catch up on uh
super chats why don't you guys hand up
the pickles
why don't we hand out the pickles yeah I
got the plates all set up you want to
grab those yeah nobody was here on
Friday because I thought I might have
covid I'll let you guys know I've tested
every day
negative yeah we seem to be in the clear
I know it's feeling a little sick of
private but
hey
I felt fine when I got home I don't know
what maybe I'll just I think they're
petite fine that burrito got you and you
were like oh God I have code
uh so I'm fine I think you know what I
mean
[Music]
but you know what this doesn't look too
bad
what doesn't this dude those are pretty
high up
somebody's definitely gonna eat [__] off
that and you know in turbulence when you
see people like get Jarred right out of
their plane so these people are going to
fall like 12 feet to the ground yeah
oh wait where's that the like tropical
storm in Thailand that blows people away
I thought that was in the dark
uh
familiar damn you know what I'm talking
about I thought I saw it in here
you know
yeah you gotta add that one oh it's on
the subreddit yeah you know what I'm
talking about I think I posted it in the
group uh let me see I'll just open the
subred I know it's there
I'm assuming it's Thailand
Zach I got something for you here
this is someone she offered proof that
it's her 21st birthday today I don't
have her name although her her Reddit
name is goose bread
21. do you see if you spread anywhere on
that ID
they gave the proof they get the sound
bite there's no proof this doesn't prove
anything ah it's it's better it's better
we're in the right place we're in the
right direction she said I want to
donate for today's podcast since it's
actually my birthday just to hear the
Sweet Melody of 21 [__] you but I felt
like the crew might not believe me so as
requested here's my proof love everyone
on the crew and I can't wait to watch
today's episode to celebrate 21. [__]
you I respect that she asked and I will
be definitely stealing your identity
with this signature you can be sure of
that
goose bread
uh happy birthday to our great Goose
bread [__] you the [__] you bro I'm sick
of this guy telling me [__] you all [__]
you [__] you [__] you [__] you Aiden
[__] you all right stop we can't say it
too many times
um
uh there was a post here about it yeah
where is it
did you find it I'm looking right now
God damn it was like right at the top oh
Blair white gets caught sexualizing
child Holocaust victim but man and Frank
the [__] excuse me what did you just say
I used Blair white gets caught okay so
she's caught she was doing this in
secret how do we sexualize Anne Frank
uh Blair white who I'm sure is on the
whole groomer thing because she's like a
total grifter mm-hmm
uh
uh let's watch it
should probably pre-screen stuff
yeah maybe
probably
it was white
probably should
what's the other thing you're looking
for Ty uh
storm or something God damn it it was
right at the top what'd you guys do with
it this is why I'm erasing the subreddit
oh oh oh oh I see
you guys is in the audience
I had a dream Dan tried to murder me yes
you read that right yesterday I had a
fold on wake up in the middle of the
night pantings scary dream that Dan was
coming to kill me Shredder was also
there for some reason as Dan's
accomplished
[__] hell yeah Shredder's got my best
forever
wouldn't you like to know
you see him somewhere I know exactly
where Shredder's is
busy
do you know where my dog is
yeah he's busy
I'll tell you if you reenact one of
those videos if you're screaming uh no I
don't know where Schreiber is yeah I
gotta keep an eye on him I don't know
where he went yes
[Music]
yeah try the regular that's
yo where is this video what the [__] is
going on well check in the chat I
definitely sent it there
Shredder not up here maybe
can you go check that he's if he's
yeah
wait
oh he was downstairs
he just wandered downstairs
hey Alfredo is he okay
Shredder
what are you doing
you're just wandered downstairs are you
[Music]
get worried about him you know he puked
a couple of times in the last couple
days and it's got me on edge
okay
so as we've as we look for uh
the Thai video I will uh go to the
bathroom and you guys try those Bubbies
and tell me if they're not the best
pickle in the world try the Bubbies all
right I'm gonna uh take a look at these
messages here let's see what we got
uh why pre-screen when you have the
button I mean true
bun only does uh 20 seconds though
currently so gotta be careful uh Jill's
Fish Room says it's not my birthday
right on
remember for 26 months shout out Jill
uh Eliza from the farm I got fired
because the horses were just the right
height a no bucket required oh my God
Eliza
guys we need to be honest
I have no idea what video I'm looking
for I haven't got a question haven't
watched it I I just know tropical
tropical he didn't send anything I
looked in our chat yeah I didn't see
anything in our chat either who made it
up you dreamed it I just want to say uh
Zach Lewis live in San Diego August oh
we're starting that now where soda bar
okay good uh small place motor bar so if
you want to get on the guest list buy
tickets
hell yeah Jessica says it's my 30th
birthday today 30 30. congrats Jessica
remember for 27 months three damn some
long time members in here
uh cliff diver King
donated 20 bucks said you guys see love
PSA video
I don't know what that means PSA did you
guys see the love PSA video
what does that mean that means I'm
afraid cliff diver you got some more
info or maybe somebody in the chat can
uh I support generally fill me in thank
you for the 20 bucks though I wish I
knew what you're talking about
uh Alex
28 month member just sent a pickle shout
out Alex
damn uh
PF Pacheco donated two bucks at AB
please check Discord I sent a vid about
this
I don't know what that's in reference to
but uh discard let him know
uh let's talk about nuking the subreddit
after Ethan nukes the bathroom that's
right
it's a good point I like your uh profile
picture there
I believe that's the cop from the uh
Jack Ruby
incident
anyways shout out
Derek runs with the five gifted
thank you for the gifted Derek runs I
think I'm really good I'm Jewish
am I Jewish I'm not uh can you talk
about Adept xqc drama hell no I'm not
come on hell no I'm talking about that
okay
uh the vaccine works
with three syringes okay well good
message Jessica
osario 11 month member
uh please tell Hassan to be at the live
show again I don't think it's happening
he's gonna be there was a plan with him
it was a very funny plan but uh yeah his
trip to Japan is going to overlap with
the live show
and I can't tell him not to go to Japan
for that sorry it is a crazy long penis
Ethan said he tried
but somebody said uh smelling farts put
hair on your chest that may be true
thank you I do want one peace and love
somebody you said Scoopy poop
fish named goat I just want a bubby
so did everybody try the bubby
do we love it
it's great right
[Music]
oh because it's a little it's very
garlicky and a little spicy
come come say what you're saying into
the Michael if you can't hear you okay
because you are uh what's that other
pickle that people were writing for
gorilla do you think it's better than
gorillo I do think it's better thank you
I'm telling you this is the Premier
pickle it is the Premier pickle you're
right it's so good I'm glad you agree
anyone else want to chime in on the
Bubbies controversy I grew up on the
Bubbies oh you know about it yeah
because you're a good Jewish boy there
you go good Jewish boy
um I just had another one and um yeah
they are really good I will say
I could see
Munchen on grillos for a longer period
of time the Bubbies is intense right
very like intense flavor I agree this is
a lot more casual I could see this all
different you know having having this
out and having a few of these whereas
one Bubby I think I'm good I agree the
Bubbies are are pretty it's a pretty
intense experience yeah well it's an old
it's an old pickle
it's an old pickle by the way the salt
content is crazy first of all serving
size is half a pickle come on come on
Bobby let's be real
tastes like beef jerky
I gotta say you guys make fun of me when
I ask for food but when I don't
I don't get it do you want some pickles
can I get a pickle they left me out too
because you want Bubbies spicy and
gorillas oh I'll try anything you can
take two full of drinks or you can take
them all I'm curious about the Bubby
spicy
Ethan said that normal is like the one
but spicy one's good I'm curious about
the spicy they're both good Ethan I have
some bad news so by the way one pickle
it was like 25 of your daily salt
yes baby what's the bad news I have no
idea what video you're talking about how
I went through no one knows we went
through the the WhatsApp chat went
through Reddit dude hold on let me find
the only information that I have is
tropical storm but then ice literally
this morning saw a post saying the crew
needs to react to this did they erase it
why would they do that
and the crew
okay hold on
I'm going through
this is the alien one no
all right you know what this isn't the
best content
just find it dude
more videos just can you give me another
clip go look for that they're at a
restaurant and they're trying to hold
down this big ass okay
um
shade
and the wind gets so strong it blows the
whole thing away and people go in the
air like 50 feet holding on to this
thing it was a tick tock
I believe it was a tick tock yeah and
was it sent in our main or was it in our
side chat
could have been either one
could be anywhere
could be anything
all right so anyway moving on here we're
going to talk about Reddit thank you
guys for your patience in this matter
[Music]
um
so uh let's see I'm gonna think some
people do you guys think all the the
subbies and uh donors and all that [__]
the post was removed why why would they
remove that
was it a tent yes it was a big ass tent
oh why does it lie
okay
people are saying the video is in your
subreddit now I just went there and it's
not there anymore I found the post okay
and it was erased right yeah why
oh confusing
how would you erase that
so I'm looking back in our chat so the
video is Khan I'm seeing there's a tick
tock uh but the link is dead so it says
The Tick Tock was removed okay they
deleted their whole profile Jesus
they have an image of it
the image is not giving me a lot but
this is this is this is one of the
people being blown away
he's it's crazy and here's another one
falling
you see that it's nuts
oh here's the tick tock you can see the
account it's user you see this maybe
yeah
on it user G q i c 4w3v
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh my God is that why
is that why
well wait
okay hold on I'm just gonna say that and
then maybe it'll give context to why
I'm reading somebody died
so maybe it's not that funny died
I I'm I don't know how someone didn't
die I mean this man was flown so high in
the air
okay somebody died
because it's not funny
walk back in sorry I had to step away if
somebody died can it still be funny
um
I I need more context I was like what
are you talking about
the video of uh
oh you found you found the video I found
an image of the video okay I found the
erased post got it look here you can see
how high up
so it's like a canopy and it gets blown
away this guy's still holding on oh
Jesus see how high up he is and then
this guy's falling
doesn't seem that funny
it is very it is I had to I have to tell
you it's funny
and it's not funny it's uh the post I
mean the uh the videos deleted from The
Tick Tock account oh yeah someone
probably died they have this video it's
not it's just a bunch of balloons being
blown away and it's not funny
I'm not surprised man that uh because
that that [__] was crazy
here I guess this is the same storm I'm
guessing not the balloon no one died in
this video I I better this one okay
somebody also dies in this one huh
oh no why are you holding a thousand
balloons in a windstorm what are you
doing
oh man
okay somebody died
I guess it's not funny then we got
bopped once a dude jumped out of a
window remember
yeah
we didn't know that they died but
YouTube's like oh we're demonetizing
because the Dude died I'm like I didn't
know when he died did he die or did he
just got seriously he died
he died
you know
but that's the internet for you so died
sometimes they die sometimes they live
all I care about is that it's funny
it's funny both of those pickles were
amazing The Joker man
both of those pickles were amazing so
you're co-signing puppy babies nice dude
I'm glad you guys love it
it really is shut up Bobby yeah
it's phenomenal
movies all right well moving on I guess
from uh our condolences
to the uh poor it was a great the poor
folks they bereaved yeah great little
side quest we just went on there sorry
about that
please uh in honor of the disgrace [__]
post with everybody
so we have posts now meta aware
for the uh the man who died
oh this is for the end of the
subredditing oh this is the Sun
all right let's talk about deleting the
subreddit
and here's what we're actually gonna do
we here decided we're going to erase the
subreddit but then we thought
let's have a debate on the show
foreign
and then together we can decide at the
end if we're going to erase it so we
need all you guys to input and frankly I
will know what you guys all think
by the way uh Aaron said she's sent you
a copy of the video AV
on Discord
I'm not going to show it but you should
show it right it's right there
what the [__] Ethan has a kid growing up
in Manhattan my friend and I had a kids
tent that blew off a 20th floor of our
building we had to find it oh nobody was
on it
it is insane they just you saw the video
yeah I just sent this it's crazy right
yeah you guys should watch it it's like
a house almost like a house tent
let me read the article and see if it
says somebody died or what I read always
in China a restaurant owner catapulted
by powerful winds plummeted onto a roof
in central China
the video filmed on June 11th
showed several individuals attempting to
cling onto the pillars supporting a
canopy but suddenly both the people and
the structures are Swept Away by
powerful gust
one person holding onto the roof was
slow to release their grip
and ended up falling from a height
landing on a nearby rooftop
on the morning of June 12th
according to a staff members real that
one of the individuals who was blown
onto the roof was none other than the
restaurant owner suffering from
fractured ribs the owners currently
receiving treatment in a hospital as a
result the restaurant has temporarily
suspended its operations fortunately no
dude nobody died
we could watch it well he got seriously
injured no he says he's in the hospital
look he fractured rib he'll be fine he
got injured off camera
he got injured off camera that injury
happens off camera but he's fine he just
fractured his rib what's the [__]
deal
them ribs the owners currently receiving
treatment in the hospital it didn't say
he's seriously injured says suffering a
fractured rib it's not even a broken rib
it's a fracture the owner is currently
receiving treatment in the hospital and
as a result boom fortunately no other
injuries were reported at the scene
further information regarding the
incidents will only be confirmed once
the owner is discharged they're fine
let's watch this [__] video
you know what I'm saying ribs
it's been built up so much at this point
I guess well I'm first of all happy that
nobody died man [__] that's good
I guess I mean it is good it is good
but all that means is let's watch
I'm worried it might get claimed I feel
like this video would be oh no it's one
thing after the other and what's
happened yesterday
viral hog already bought it
exactly what I thought I feel like
viralog I'm watching it I don't give a
[__]
after all this type
here it is
[Music]
look at everybody's pitching in I mean
it's inspiring
everybody's pitching in you know that's
China now would be proud
oh this is a difference oh no I got I
got the right angle it'll come here's
the other guy oh this one has everything
yeah we got this one I saw
yo whoa Okay so
first there's two there's two things to
watch for it happens so fast this dude
right here let's go
hey let's go fast look how hot he hangs
on the guy look at this look at us at
Apes Fest look at that that's such a
gnarly fall
sounds like the roof actually saved him
[__] me dude listen I know it happens
fast but that guy he's the owner man
he's you know what I mean he's like I'm
going down with the ship
yeah it's heroic dude he's a he's a real
one for that
oh Lord
oh that's him
dude what a [__] Legend
no way
that is awesome
[Music]
holy smokes
that guy's badass
yeah I think just another day at the
office no one's helping him
you know and it's pretty impressive to
hold on that much because I'm a fat ass
I don't think I could hold myself up
like that anymore we need to go to that
restaurant have you been there that
thing wouldn't have fallen away yo you
know that restaurant is it's probably so
[__] good he works so hard that's
what I'm saying you know that food is
insane if they were willing to put their
life on the line for some dumplings or
whatever
yeah
that is a Chinese cuisine don't come
here don't come at me
[Laughter]
oh my God
yo he just walks out it's fine he's
pretty old looking he's like peace I
gotta get back to the dumplings his
tables
seems kind of dope there in a way I
don't know China seems kind of cool
looking at this
apparently nothing's nailed down but
other than that
I mean look at I love this slow-mo
holy [__]
so crazy [__] geez look at that amount
of rain though goddamn so there it is
nobody died it's a great video Leave Me
Alone
it's a great video
in fact I honor the owner for being
[__] God
dumpling God in it and a pair of
paragliding God
okay so anyway back to Reddit
back to Reddit
okay
here we go Reddit here we are the title
of the episode
we've had enough
so of course we're talking about should
we join the um
the Reddit boycott oh not permanently
erased
oh
babe are you confused is that what you
thought I meant well you you said that
verbatim about five months ago I'm just
talking about there's a big boycott on
Reddit and I wanted to Let's explore why
it's happening and if we should join the
boycott oh interesting I wasn't even
supposed to be here today it's the only
reason I showed up right
we have a poll that I put up uh just
prior to going live today it's currently
at 43 487 votes and people want should
we nuke the subreddit and the yes is
winning uh 54 to 46 so working on that
pickle pack
oh speaking of gorillos spilled all over
me and I smell like a giant grillos
girl
I'll take it all right so here's the
deal here's what's happening on reddit
reddit has decided
to so if there's third-party apps they
access reddit's API
to um make a third-party software for it
and um Reddit has a
their own app which is horrible horrible
unusable
and there is a app that people use a lot
that they love which is third party
called Apollo
that's the biggest one for people on
iPhones do you use it or do I don't use
it I should well you're not going to be
able to in a few days it's about to it's
about to get shut down
so they increased the I the API
usage charge to something like insane
it's raising from like hundreds of
dollars to like tens of thousands of
dollars no no from free
oh yeah it's free and now they're going
to start charging money to access it
very similar to what Twitter recently
did that Elon Musk got a lot of [__] for
and it killed a bunch of third-party
apps on Twitter as well well what I
understand is like It's Not Unusual to
charge it's the amount they're charging
correct
which is crazy
um here is
it's just alone
a bunch of people say love Apollo
Apollo's goaded yeah I think I wish I
knew about it
yeah it's only for uh iPhone I use a
similar one for Android called reddit is
fun um which is also being shut down by
this they have a similar problem
where it's just not anywhere worth it
for them to continue
it's it seems pretty obvious that they
set the price at a point that the
intention is to kill these apps off they
want people to use their the official
Reddit app because there's ads on it
well there's ad there's ads on it um
they can monetize it otherwise other
ways that can maybe introduce
subscriptions later whatever they just
they want people using the official
Reddit app well which wouldn't be a huge
deal if it didn't suck [__] ass the
reason I hate one of the reasons I hate
the Reddit app is because there's so
many [__] ads on it they integrate so
many ads so I understand why they want
people using it in that regard but okay
so let's find out if we want to join
this boycott or not what is this we're
looking at
7968 out of 830 300 8304 so I think this
is how many Subs have publicly committed
to joining this all of these I think
eight three eight thousand 304 which
ones have committed to it and
7968 is how many have gone private so
far what the [__] there's only 336
public Reddit
no that's not all of the subreddits
again the that's just of ones that have
publicly said we will be joining the
boycott okay okay I see you okay well
there it is Reddit
earlier in the day this number was you
know this was a lot more active because
they were all very quickly shutting down
now most of them have shut down so it's
slowed down a little bit but this is a
live feed
um let's take a look at some of the
subreddits that have gone private
they're pretty funny actually
um [__] wife has gone private
what will we do without [__] wife uh
porn what does that say porn sugami
okay
that's a thousand yo what are we gonna
do without [__] wise you're over 500 000
uh subscribers on [__] wife that's one
of the that is really popular I want to
know something's going on but isn't our
that's about the same size as our
subreddit is it not I think we're about
500 000. we have 570.
um
this is a live stream uh there's another
link uh in the doc that's just a written
list of all of the subs
um organized by how big they are so you
can get impression of uh
[Music]
so it's number one by the way it's the
first link in the section okay so here's
all the ones going and by the way the
drama on this is really interesting the
CEO kit did an AMA trying to justify it
and got absolutely flamed and it is very
entertaining but here's a list of all
the great subreddits we're losing
bunny
where will we be without that one of the
worst subreddits on the site
um these are have a lot man I mean
they're the big ones these are all like
the front page Subs essentially like if
you if you are not logged into Reddit
you don't have your own Subs these are
most of the default ones fantastic
has over a million
followers they're in the 1 million plus
hashtag our [__]
our bras uh our buses petite
bras
oh yeah a lot of porn on Reddit oh yeah
I'm pretty sure that's like 80 of why
people use Reddit at this point
uh are cream pies of course where would
he be without cream pies that's a
cooking subreddit
let's not forget crypto markets oh good
garyvee
no uh let's see what else we got here
yeah this this is this is bad this is
really gonna hit them hard
yeah so I mean if you try and go to any
of these subreddits on this list right
now
um
most of them are private
Hentai Hentai gifts
[__]
hold my feeding tube
it's all porn that one's actually not
born I'm subbed to hold my feeding tube
yeah I found some uh videos for the show
on that one that's not a porn so I read
it no it's like uh hold my beer but but
like way worse way worse okay
oh man some of these Niche porn ones are
so funny but these aren't even Niche
these all have over a million yeah on
that Niche I guess
um uh let's see here I'm looking through
too
not all
but a lot not seeing a lot of porn down
here
tiny tits
wait wasn't this traps
wasn't this the one that that the
quartering got enforced yeah well oh
wait Force creep wait Force oh that was
forced forced cream pie I don't think
that's what it was it was um like our
coerced orgasm this one is forced orgasm
I see has uh Gone Dark oh is that I
thought that was the Germany one but I
guess that was that's another orgasm
suddenly gay they closed down during
Pride months suddenly gay
well we could be on this list of 500k
Plus
this could be us this could be us
we have to join the boycott fast our
serial killers
are serial our sexy tummy oh here's one
[__] so here is braless interesting
the bra subreddit has more than the bra
list subreddit what does that mean
interesting it's uh in the drain our
breeding
I'm sure that's just about like horses
and stuff like that definitely
crackhead Craigslist
um
dirty pen pals
that's that's some old school uh erotica
right there dirty pen pals
Penthouse Forum that's some 19th century
eat extras what with three X's e x x
extras
I'm sure that's just about uh
xxxtentacion I'm sure yeah that's just
about uh extras on the uh
film set I feel that we're we we need to
consolidate uh we need to support the
people
we where would we be without rape my
[__]
that one's gone
this subreddit rim job Steve what is
that
like genuinely there's just a dude Steve
who's into rim jobs and he has a massive
subreddit I mean
rim job Steve is if he's can go out and
so can we
I'm in solidarity with him
um
oh apparently Rim's job Steve
is a subreddit where people write
particularly wholesome or nice comments
but the person who wrote it has a
horrific username I guess it was
started when somebody with the username
[__] Steve posted something very like
insightful
that's incredible half a million and
what would Reddit be without barely
making the list here something so creepy
and vile Young Girls Gone Wild
barely making the cut there
[Laughter]
what the [__]
all right so what's the drama let's take
a look well it's the drama
um so by the end of this we're gonna
decide uh blah blah blah a massive
amount of subreds are going private in
protests of reddit's upcoming API
Changed by Reddit CEO Steve Huffman
I don't I don't like him I can tell from
the names Huffman Steve Huffman okay uh
you know
as we're gonna see in the course of the
story there's something about being the
owner or the CEO of a social media
website that's him yeah that's Bad Luck
Brian
[Music]
but that's literally Bad Luck Brian
hold that Meme up yeah
bro how do you look like that
does him
oh is that not him go over that's him
all right so this is Steve Huffman
yeah but between him and like Elon and
[__] Zuck yeah like and Jack you just
have to be a [__] weirdo and run one
of these things
or does it make you a weirdo I don't
know I don't know I thought Jack was
like kind of normal and cool but
apparently he's like super anti-vaxx
he's why why did you have to do that
okay and all of his like pseudo mystical
[__] like I I can't stand him jacket
oh so let's talk so here's the
background May 31st read it announced
they're raising the price of access to
the API from being free to a level that
would kill every third party app on
Reddit from Apollo to reddit is fun to
narwhal to bacon reader and I guess a
lot of people have put a lot of time and
effort
and livelihood into building these apps
and they're just basically
killing them all which again I would say
wouldn't be as big of a deal if Reddit
could just get their [__] together and
make an app that doesn't suck like
that's why I use it like the the mobile
experience that they offer is awful I I
really like the app that I use it's
super quick I don't understand how one
dude can make a better app than this
like billion dollar company yeah okay
this will make third-party apps like
Apollo Reddit I read that the developers
of Apollo the largest of them all
said that his app usage fee would cost
him about 2 million per month
what why even make that an option
2 million per month speculation about
the cause of this move is mostly focused
on the fact that Reddit wants to go
public
oh that that's gonna go really good for
them
phase up Reddit yeah it's such a
such a bad idea
uh they want to go public on the stock
market by the end of this year by
killing third-party apps they
ethereatically want to drive users to
their own and house Reddit app which
they can monetize for uh far more easily
and with ads yada yada other features
this escalated when details of a phone
meeting
oh this is [__] juicy gossip bro
uh details of a phone meeting between
Apollo's Dev and reddit's admins meant
to figure out a path forward for Apollo
where uh were shared by the Apollo guy
the rumor started to come out from
Reddit that the CEO Steve Hoffman Bad
Luck Brian username spez was claiming
that Apollo threatened us
said they they'll make it easy if Reddit
gave them 10 million the guy behind the
scenes is coercing us he's threatening
us so he said that publicly he didn't
say it publicly but it started to leak
out and what triggered all of this is
the Apollo guy started getting reached
out to by journalists to comment how did
it get leaked out because I guess the
CEO is just running his mouth to
everybody at the company and you know
people talk to reporters so so the CEO
he didn't make like a public statement
at first about it but he was going
around bad-mouthing the guy claiming
that he tried to Black and like to
extort them essentially that story
doesn't make any sense why would they
pay him 10 million dollars
for what
it's a good question uh Steve they're
like well no I have no idea well that's
the thing ironically by doing that they
gave him the leverage that they were
worried about because now he's leading a
revolt on the website and got half the
website turning itself off okay well
hold on he actually recorded the phone
call
so this is pretty juicy
um yeah so he's in Canada uh which is a
one that's what I did consent bbtv shout
out love my Canadians so he when he
heard this rumor uh going around he's
like yo I recorded the call here it is
and I love this
roll it
um
and that's a yearly uh apparently
ongoing cost to you folks if you want to
rip that Band-Aid off once
um and get and have Apollo uh quiet down
um you know six months yeah beautiful
deal but again this was mostly a joke
I'm just saying that if the opportunity
cost is that High
um you know and if there's something
that would make this easier on you guys
that could happen too but but um I'm
just saying as is it's quite I hear you
and I I understand that you're like as
an illustrator okay yeah yeah yeah it's
just um you know I I think it's this is
what you know what you mean by quiet
down because I find that to be I don't
know no no no no sorry I didn't mean
that it would be very straightforward
with you too it feels like a threat and
like I'm just like oh interesting
because you know one of the things that
we're trying to do is to say Hey you
have been using our apis free of costs
for many many years so hopefully you
mean something completely different from
what I said but when you say like go
quietly I just want to what did you what
did how did you take that sorry could
you elaborate oh like because because
you were like hey if you want us if you
want this to go away like that I said if
you want apology to go quiet like in
terms like I would say it's quite loud
in terms of apis
sorry that's a that's a complete
misinterpretation
I apologize I apologize immediately no
no no because you know what we're
hearing in some conversations as folks
are you know like in in other making
threats and you're just like hey that's
not conversation that we want to have so
I I immediately apologize no no it's all
good I'm sorry if it sounded like that
it's asking you to repeat it
misheard it no no no no yeah
um but yeah yeah yeah he thought he
misinterpreted something as a threat for
like a second the guy was like no no I
didn't mean it like that I meant like
this oh okay I that's totally my fault I
misunderstood I'm sorry like he he
apologizes like four times wow and then
after this call starts telling everybody
yeah he's trying to extort us that's
pretty great I mean that couldn't be any
better of a recorded phone call as much
as possible
yeah that would be the opposite
fantastic fantastic fantastic I'm taking
up enough of your time thank you very
much um I'm here yeah so that's that's
like just a malicious lie listening to
this that's pretty wild
spez
dumb ass [__] look at this idiot this
is the CEO of Reddit
I knew I've recognized him
that's good that's the kid that's the
same person how did bad luck I guess Bad
Luck Brian found some good luck and he's
the CEO of Reddit now
uh suppose you're an idiot dude dumbass
Stick it to the Man Apollo
bbtv vibes
so despite admitting he 100
misunderstood the 10 of what Apollo said
spez went on to tell everyone that
Apollo was threatening them
Apollo guy spilled the beans in this uh
Reddit thread which currently has
two hundred and ten thousand upvotes
okay well so here is
the Apollo guy posting about it
that's a lot of upvotes and it goes into
a lot of detail about
everything essentially
uh let's see here hail's been a amazing
run thank you apparently they've been
doing this for eight years what happened
initially Reddit announced it would
start changing their IPA
when did they announce the pricing
yada yada why did you say redis pricing
is too high by what metric reddit's
promise was that the pricing would be
Equitable and based on reality the
reality that they themselves have posted
data about over the years as follows
Apollo's price would be approximately
250 per month per user which Reddit
indicated cost being approximately 12
cents per their own numbers a 20x
increase does not seem based in reality
to me 250 per user per month for a free
app that's
insane
why doesn't Reddit just buy Apollo
that's a good idea if Apollo has an
apparent opportunity cost of 20 million
per year why not just buy them
uh I believe it's a fair question if
these apps apparently cost so much an
easy solution would be likely make
everyone happy you the reason that
reddit's app sucks when a pause is good
is because Reddit has a profit incentive
and so they are forced to program it in
a way
that's kind of annoying because they
need to make money whereas the Apollo
guy has no profit incentive and he can
do it in a way that's just like user
friendly at night when he does make
money off of it because you can get like
a premium subscription on or whatever
which according to him it's about like 8
000 people do out of the millions of
people that use this app so it's very
small but that's how he like kind of
keeps it going 8 000 times five I
imagine I don't know how much it is but
yeah probably 40 000 a month
uh and then after 24 hours I received
this odd message on Mastodon
hey Christian uh can you please comment
publicly about the internal Reddit claim
that you tried to Blackmail them for 10
million dollars he never even said that
number
he did say 10 million at some point but
he he was that conversation was
essentially the part that you just read
through about the opportunity costs like
what when people are asking him why
don't they just buy it he was suggesting
that and I mean he says that I'm mostly
joking he like frames it that way but
you know he is kind of floating the idea
or whatever
um of trying to get a Payday from this
or whatever but yeah why not why not
just buy me out Apollo threatened us and
said they'd make it easy if Frederick
gave them 10 million this guy behind the
scenes is coursing us he's threatening
us
he says that's not what happened
me I said if you want Apollo to go quiet
like in terms of I would say it's quite
loud in terms of the API usage oh go
quiet isn't that okay God you got you
sorry that's complete institution I
apologize we heard that
uh yada yada whatever he knows the whole
script the transcript of the entire call
there and then he posted the audio
excerpt that we listened to as well damn
this guy wrote up a [__] Bible That's
what I'm saying like you slammed him
holy [__]
okay so so then
um
this caused a massive black lash
including current blackouts somehow ran
it man read it managed to make it worse
when Bad Luck Brian aka spez the CEO did
an AMA and as you know you would think
that he knows because
this is like kind of a history of people
doing disastrous amas on Reddit and like
it the fact that the CEO had his own is
it's pretty ironic so
despite Apollo already showing the
receipts spez decided to double down on
his accusation okay interesting here's
his post
uh addressing the community about
changes to our IPA it has zero points of
course API API has zero points 32 000
comments and it he's at negative 5 500
points DPI so here he he left this
supplementary comment he said his quote
joke is the least of our issues his
behavior and Communications with us has
been all over the place saying one thing
to us while saying something completely
different externally recording and
leaking a private phone call to the
point where I don't know how we could do
business with them this is what this is
what people do when they get caught they
go I can't believe you recorded the
phone call yeah it's like
um yeah that's why he recorded it he
wouldn't never have to put it out if he
didn't try to [__] lie to lie about
him yeah that's the same thing we did
with BBC and then that's him responding
by the way the uh I am whatever that
username says okay so he said
please feel free to give examples where
I said something differently in public
versus what I said to you I'll give you
full permission he didn't respond to
that he did not respond
very interesting so he got bodied for
that
uh now there's a massive amount of
subreds including many of the sites
Vegas have blacked out in protest so
that's where we're here I guess that
brings us up to uh
current date yeah yeah so
you know
to kind of tie it into what you were
saying earlier I mean our audience right
now is at 54 saying just nuke the
subreddit entire permanently erase yeah
just permanently erase it damn you guys
are brutal yeah I don't necessarily
think we should do that we've gotten a
lot of great content from this already
despite its flaws yeah but it's been a
good run
yeah
you're in favor all right let's move on
come on you know let's just erase the
show in protest no not that far
but the Reddit well if YouTube doesn't
fix their app that's what I was saying
earlier I think we should delete our
YouTube channel too in protest yeah
we'll teach them
I'll show them so I guess I mean listen
I I'm not I'm a man of the people listen
summer X just uh donated said please
delete it please there's a lot of people
asking to delete it please several
people are asking we beg you please
everybody's asking you to to leave
what lost is it to Reddit if these Subs
go dark and the third party app users
don't come back to Reddit when Reddit is
not making money uh is it making money
off these users anyway sounds like a
pointless protest in a sense that is a
good question because one I don't think
Reddit is profitable they're not by
their own admission so then which is
also why it's kind of why they're trying
to IPO this year but so in a sense like
you have to understand from a business
perspective there's this website we all
use and the third party guy is make is
making money and red it's not so and
that's their logic and in that sense it
that does make sense because ultimately
their business is not going to work
but obviously the the CEO is not
explaining it in a good faith way if you
said that people would understand right
and again their initial promise
that oh we're gonna have to start
charging for the API
which by the way there like there was
some backlash and pushback at that point
but not anywhere near like the the
developers were all eagerly waiting more
information because it's like okay we
might have to adjust things a little bit
to compensate for this but we can make
it work and then as soon as they dropped
the info about what it was going to cost
I mean I think my my app on reddit
reddit is fun or whatever I think that
same day sent a push notification my
phone that the app would be shutting
down in 30 days so like they saw the
pricing and just everyone was like oh
this is just this is a joke this just
means we have to just shut down see if
they would have just been up front and
did a post like we're not profitable we
have to do this people would be like
that sucks but I get it yeah there would
definitely still be backlash but all of
it speaks yeah this [__] [__] is
doing just he's so pathetic and it's so
bad
um and we should stand with the People
by deleting
yeah so in a sense is the protest
we're pro to I never used that I never
use a third-party app
that's shocking to me so you use the
default Reddit app I used the web
browser
[__] crazy oh but I've been on is
that better than the app like you would
rather there's no ads on it it's pretty
annoying because sometimes you have like
if it's a mature content label you have
to open it in the app right okay so
that's pretty annoying but uh well I
would suggest you start using Apollo but
uh kind of pointless at this point
well it seems like
it's gone like there's no going back
they're not gonna they've made their
decision I don't think that they're
gonna go back on this and I mean this
this protest while it's interesting to
just show the scale of like the user
base that is upset about this
um
I mean it's it's pre-planned to be a
two-day thing so everybody went private
today and they would stay private
tomorrow and then it would come back
Wednesday so if you pre-announce that oh
this is a limited uh
protests that we're doing they'll just
wait it out like
I don't think it's gonna affect Reddit
at all
frankly
and but I I guess I support the guy but
at this end of the day if you think
about what he should have said it makes
sense I mean they're not profitable as a
company
yeah the other side of this issue though
is just by causing this huge backlash
um
and shutting down these third-party apps
that basically make your website usable
on a phone
um they probably will lose a decent
amount of users over this I doubt it you
don't think so there's no website like
Reddit there's just nowhere else to
consume
uh media
the way that Reddit does I don't see it
it's like it's become such a Mainstay of
the internet I just I don't see that
there's a alternative for it where are
you going to get a page like rim job
Brian yeah dude where are you going to
get milk
squirt porn or our bra brawl whatever
the raw and brawler yeah he's just not
out there man but
gotta stick to our guns here delete
all in I'm awesome I'm all in turn the
key I personally don't feel I have a
horse in this race one thing I will say
is uh
I don't
I don't know if they were profitable and
it was just a greed move then it's like
[__] them Elite but I get the problem is
I understand why they need to do this
even though he didn't explain it well
he's explained to horrible well and so
their initial from what I understand and
now it's getting a little bit more in
the weeds of like the back and forth
that they had and so forgive me if I get
any of these details wrong but the
initial implication that they gave when
they announced hey we're going to have
to start charging for the API is that
the charging would be to cover costs and
what right they like the Apollo guy is
saying is like this is this is like 20x
what the cost is I understand right that
the CEO is a liar and a dumbass okay
but ultimately I just don't know that
and I think we need to erase those sub
permanently
the people keep saying YouTube crashed
what the [__] dude I'm telling you
delete YouTube delete YouTube why can't
they fix this [__] delete delete
wait I think I found a picture of the
new you know uh YouTube got a new CEO
well I found out why it keeps crashing
here's the new CEO oh
it's just just Steve again
did they respond to our thing like hello
yeah they did respond they could always
respond but they don't do anything hello
oh this must have been the biggest crash
yet because I've never seen this many
Spanish
holy moly uh let's see what did they say
thanks again for flagging could you tell
us more stop saying that
they're not doing anything they just say
can you tell us more what
to do we'll take screenshots replied
there are the replies with with what's
then look at do YouTubers telling people
we recommend trying to clear your cash
and cookies and uninstall and reinstall
the app they're they're not doing
anything that could
I could maybe help at least temporarily
this many people that seems like a
isolated yeah
wow you know what I noticed and I don't
know if it's related
but they just recently added like the
kind of like Instagram live or Tick Tock
live thing where you can like
smash emojis and it does a little
bubbling up from the bottom thing you
know what I'm talking about yeah you can
do that on YouTube yeah I don't see that
yeah it's not on for everybody I saw it
on your screen it's on your screen right
now
mine no uh ABS you see what I'm talking
about all the hearts yeah the bottom
right corner yeah I don't get that yeah
um and I think it's on mobile too I
wonder because it does a lot of people
seem to indicate it seems to be the chat
that was having issues if that's like
[__] things up because that's a
pretty big update to the chat feature I
see it on mobile you see it on mobile
now too
guys put screenshots and stuff I don't
know I keep saying that it's like it's
like a joke at this point
uh erase your cookies what the [__] me
saying
cookies for you I've mostly seen people
say they're fine on Android I have had a
few people say no I'm on Android and I
have crash though so it doesn't
Apple why are they not taking this
seriously it seemed like it was just an
iOS thing and the majority of people do
seem to have IOS problems I'm responding
them it's only happening
on live
and
I don't know what screen shot
or info
people
could provide
[Music]
other than it just saying it crashed
yeah I see a lot of people saying yeah
Chad is sticky chat keeps freezing for a
while our
sharing that image that's right chat's
right I think I know the issue
I think there's a weird thing going on
with our subreddit and correlation to
the YouTube and I think we need to you
think it's connected somehow yeah we
just gotta cut it off just cut it all
off Zach you you have a vendetta it
sounds like you have a personal vested
interest in making seeing that the
subreddit is launched into orbit without
a doubt yeah it's my life's mission
I'll defend our subreddit listen they've
come for all are there are there are
there toxic people on there yes are
there constant repos yes
is there dog [__] suggestions yes where
are everybody on there annoying yes is
everybody on there you're really making
a case here Dan however however I'm in
therapy because of that [__]
subreddit
that might be true yeah
I got my teeth shaved down because that
subreddit yeah well hold on hold us up
what I got my two front teeth shaved
down you did in that [__] flock of
photos so much you did that this is new
a b lore yeah you went to a dentist and
had them shave your front teeth yeah
I've been thinking about doing it for a
while let me see you can't tell it that
wasn't the problem yeah I thought it was
the problem but that wasn't it didn't
fix the problem
you had your teeth filed and it didn't
even do anything no well I wanted to
follow them anyway just straighten them
out wait so what what's the pro so that
didn't fix it so what do we think is the
problem have we identified what next we
need to adjust
all right there's there's the doctor
recommended a few things what do we do
what's down the pipeline
uh so that was a stress-induced facial
tick is what the tennis said she said
there's something called uh gummy lip
Botox that can be done right here maybe
did you show a doctor the flock of face
I uh no oh my God bro
did you do that he did that you showed
the doctor in the Flocka face
yeah maybe I wanted to love them
maybe but I really want to talk to you
because
I've said this from when I started like
I just been that way my whole life
including my siblings like we just I
don't know we have uh
I don't know the term for it but we
always just think we look [__] up so
yeah I think your ex the photo
definitely doesn't help scene all the
time I've ever extra hard on yourself
but if this made you feel good then
obviously we support so wait where does
that come from do one of your parents
have a similar
uh issue like how does that get passed
down to all to both brothers I don't
know but like my sister like my sister
who's very pretty like
has like eating issues because of it my
brother has bad anxiety I don't know
where we get it from
huh
is your mother bro it seems that your
mom is very uh conscious about the way
she looks and stuff just based on what I
saw is she did she ever maybe put
indirect pressure on you guys to look a
certain way or um no I mean both my
parents are good looking they just uh no
I I don't know maybe we heard the way
they were talking about other people or
something I'm not sure did they gossip
about how other people look sometimes
around you kids they just they're just
[__] talkers in general interesting I
don't think it was specifically about
people's looks
I'm not trying to I genuinely I feel for
you I'm just I wish you could I wish you
could feel what how I feel about it
because I know it's just hey me me too
if only you could see what I see because
Lena try to like talk you out of this
like showing the doctor the Flocka
picture or she she just supports you
because she knows that's just how you
are and she just knows that's how I am
whatever it's gonna bring me less stress
I think she supports
so so you shave down your teeth
and then there's also a lip injection
you can do do you mind if I pull up the
Flocka photo
sure wait you got it well I just want to
see what you're trying to address no is
that okay is that a lip injection
no I'm saying that that's uh it's an
option that's an option so wait did you
go to a plastic surgeon no no the
dentist recommended it if I really
wanted to but it's meant for people with
buck teeth which I don't have but it if
you want it would stop the nerve from
reacting but I don't it doesn't happen
that often so here's the Flop can I pull
this up sure it's one of the top Google
results go for it because I always just
want to know what it is we're trying to
address here
I mean look at that so and every time I
make the face people are sure to grab it
okay but you just puked that's just like
your lips are just like held back is
that just one bad photo it doesn't
doesn't say anything about you oh I feel
bad that it hurt that it's like because
I'm Healed
so then what's the lip thing how the
lips are pulled back to show the front
teeth is that the issue
yeah I I isn't it just like a single
frame like if you went frame by frame
isn't it like you're just like mid
talking or something yeah it's just real
quick so you can do that to anybody
literally hold on so you can you can
conceptualize that
you can't do this
that you don't look like this but at the
same time
you feel like an irrational urge or what
what is the feeling
like you know you know like logically
what me and Dan are saying is true or
you right yes no I I see both yeah
yeah exactly Oh either left a comment
I'm busted no no she just said
she said oh my God A B no
I I I 100 know what you mean though like
I I've been there so I'm not I'm not
judging you at all I just find it
fascinating by the way I had my two
front teeth shaved down too when I was a
kid
I had an accident where I slammed my
teeth into like a monkey bar oh and it
chipped like crazy and they had to shave
down is it crazy that those were just
like [__] iron cages that they had us
like around with so they don't do that
anymore right can we switch off over
concrete yeah over concrete
so the problem is the mouth area for you
is that the issue
that day is just everything is my eyes
my teeth I was I don't know it's weird
it's hard like I'm confident at the same
time like it's a weird it's weird
I don't know you were literally just I
walked stumbled out of the bathroom
after puking yeah you were really
unexpected to look right I got even like
a dime you had everything else you were
rolling this is like totally this is
It's that's why it's funny it's like
it's funny because it's a B in the
aftermath of a disaster I completely
understand yeah but it's also you know
maybe flock is aged out
[Music]
hmm dude I I have taken bat we all taken
bad photos where we look [__] up
that's why some people say I'm
photogenic I'm not photogenic some
people look good at photos from do that
I mean a b I'm not again I'm not saying
like oh you shouldn't feel some type of
way because I know it's out of your
control but at the same time
I mean we all take we all take photos
that's not even photoshopped
you know what I mean it's just it
happens to everybody such a powerful
image my God it's [__] insane
this is look how small my hands look too
everything it's all bad
I wish I could get through to you but uh
are you in therapy about this kind of
stuff baby or you've considered it no
no
I'm I'm
good
okay all right he's good let's leave him
alone I know you didn't expect for this
to be a whole thing when you brought it
up but I'm fascinated by it
so you shave down your two front teeth
how much do they take off can you show
me again very very minimum just a little
bit
it looks I mean it looks good it looks
very straight yeah it looks good
that might be a little too short no I'm
just kidding
was it painful no yeah
no
just the thought of that gives me the
chills it wasn't painful when they did
to me but it just felt super weird and
you could feel like the the bone dust
the sound would just drive me insane
yeah like some people after braces if
they're baby teeth or if they're like
grown in teeth are still rich
if they like still have their ridges
they'll uh they'll shape them down you
know if you go to that Google photo I
mean the Google search whatever you
search I could where you saw the photos
myself yeah can you bring can you bring
that up for a sec sure if you insist
a b Flocka H3 podcast is what I had to
type
so do you want the whole the whole thing
of it yeah okay you see that picture of
me
the second one yes no to the right this
one you got that one okay
okay
the day after okay but your teeth don't
show like that I know they don't I don't
it's it's a stress induced facial kick
they've learned they literally don't so
are you you're biting your bottom lip
with your two middle teeth is that yeah
my uh
I like I don't know it makes these nasty
ass uh
Peter Pettigrew face as the subreddit
pointed out I know I I
haven't done it in a while do you that's
from the same episode right you don't
stay like you're in motion when it yeah
yeah I'm not stuck like it yeah yeah
it's it's real quick it's because people
take screenshots right yeah yeah and
people shouldn't take screenshots love
what is your point here what are you
trying to say I was just saying he's
like a cutie patootie in the whole
episode
do you like the photo of you on the left
no both of these are great yeah this is
the photo I posted this is the one you
like yeah both of them are but this one
you look good you look I was fine with
the one on the right this is my this is
my post
I see he posted these so so the
procedure is a shot in the lips is it
like a Botox thing yeah it's a Botox
thing the dentist would do that or he
would say no no no no she recommended me
to uh plastic surgery someone else that
does it yeah or a cosmetic surgeon and
it stops the the nerves from reacting I
guess that's what Botox does right yeah
so wait are you considering doing that
and don't you have to keep up the botox
to because it's not just a one-time
thing yeah I'm not sure I think it's
like once every year like several months
that's a lot that's a lot of work
everything months several months yeah
did you know that these Botox people
they have to keep yeah I know you got to
redo it but I thought maybe it would
last longer than a few months so are you
considering um
the the lip injection
I consider it it depends let's see if
we'll see if uh
how much more guys no
buck tooth screenshots of baby on the
suburb ever ever again what about this
one
foreign
let's show this man some love oh there's
a subreddit R flaca yep
hold the phone has it gone dark yes
get off the screen Ian
Flocka is not done we're in an unknown
territory here I just want to see the
top post of all time well are they dark
right now in in protest no they're not
they're not that's weird they're scabs
this is a subreddit of love oh yeah no I
know okay good these people are honoring
you
what
these are pretty funny why don't they
both season the subway
Community it was probably cross-posted
okay so we don't like this subreddit
well [__] is the sound bite and you
you're you're all about the sound bite
like your signature that was before yeah
then that'd be just because someone
became somehow
they turned it against you so are you
are you gonna oh see that's that see you
don't look like that
foreign
[Music]
that's not even a real thought well you
know that's an edit right what really
[__] me up is when people are
defending me and they're like it's okay
guys some people have lazy eyes I'm like
that's a [__] edit my eyes aren't
lazy like not that one specifically but
there's some of the flocks yo this is
awesome I'm sorry this is so funny face
off Abdullah versus a b
ah
I love it I look in the mirror and I see
the the face on the right the flock of
face there's nothing wrong with that
face by the way
[Music]
you know what I mean nothing wrong with
that face both of those faces someone
related did you see it what Abe tweeted
last night no
you should crack me up baby
it was scary accurate oh yeah I saw this
post on the subredditor or maybe I saw
you read Twitter and I did see it that
is so
so [__] awesome
does every Lebanese couple looks like
this and this is like this is from last
year let's post how did you dig this up
that is funny man
is scary accurate
that is so good
YouTube crashed again I see the Live use
fluctuating like 500 all the time he
doesn't want to let us get past 40K yeah
I noticed that too it just drops like
hard for no hard limit at forty thousand
hmm
a little Saucy well Ava you are
undoubtedly the most handsome you are
the heartthrob you understand that right
thank you yeah
come on now
yeah I know it's I I know it's I know
it's me I'm not
yeah I appreciate you being honest
because I love this stuff
you know um
I think it's a good segments I think
this
the subreddit and the intense
scrutiny we get in there has caused some
people on this show to be less open
than they used to be
and so that is I guess the potential
side effect of having the subreddit uh
but you know
I don't I feel like that's gonna happen
no matter what but sometimes people get
a little carried away about stuff and I
don't know
yeah it's a it's a love hate thing
because it is also nice to see uh you
know the response when you like you know
and Ian does a good segment and seeing
that the audience loves it or whatever
it is but at the same time uh and also
like just finding stories for the show
it's very helpful because it's a bunch
of people who know what we like to talk
about so yeah it is a love hey like if
we were to ban it for just a couple days
I know that uh writing the episode for
Wednesday would be more difficult yeah
we got so much juice from the subreddit
I was memeing earlier when I was listing
off all the negatives without saying any
positives I'm I
we have a great subreddit yeah compared
to most other
um
uh what do you call it like internet
shows or podcasts or whatever our
subreddit is extremely active um which
is Super Active the people that post
there are like really good content good
suggestions and stuff
and it's been the origin of a lot of
like the the best segments that we've
done on the show yeah Community
subreddit and everything no it's it's
genuinely a big asset to the show the
problem is that the Flocka thing is
funny and everybody's enjoying it but I
guess you forget the human aspect of
that a b actually is looking at that and
feeling bad about it right
I you know
damn
teeth filed down
how much that cost
I forget I had I had some other work
done just and I did it while I was there
oh he's kind of grouped up yeah together
word of advice about teeth uh don't go
to an orthodontist when you're young go
when you're a little older because I
have to start the [__] process over
again you're gonna get braces I'm
getting Invisalign
I have a gap between in my jaw moved
just a London look
going to what Abe said I'm
self-conscious about it man it sucks I
used to really want to shave a gap in my
teeth
but um yeah I have to start the whole
[__] process over again shitty wow
you don't have to I don't have to I want
to though okay do what you know what I
support people doing what they need to
to feel uh comfortable and happy with
themselves it is what it is
you know what um there's actually some
good news about the subreddit
a psych there's none
uh after all of these years
very recently I only discovered it like
last week but um
they have finally implemented uh
alt blocking when when you
suspend somebody or ban somebody from a
subreddit until like last week all they
had to do was go sign up for a new
account on a new email
and go post on that
now IP you have the IP and I think even
um
like device ID so like if it's if you're
on
love that so you can't get around it
with VPN even like if you're on the same
device I'm sure if you really knew what
you were doing but for like the average
person it is actually going to prevent
you hear that from
continuously coming back
so anyway though let's get back to the
segment
so all in all do we want to join the
protest and go dark for two days or do
we want to say
men walking their own path
and what does that mean deleting the
subreddit
say what what is what is the alternative
what just going private sorry deleting's
not on the table I'm sorry oh [__] all
right well can I go home now like that
was the only reason you're here when I
came today no you cannot go home Zach
wait till the show's over I I got [__] I
wanted to watch it go down and fall like
it was the oh wait that was everyone
crashed again [__] hold on literally the
whole chat is just crashed everybody
just crashed what is happening thread it
dude it's so [__] dumb
people are saying it's the 40K
it was happening earlier but it does
seem to like become more frequent well
we haven't crossed 40K since this
crashing started it like you know
that would make sense if the shot is the
one because that the more people
watching the higher the people are
shouting I guess that might be why it's
crashing because it gets overloaded wait
I wonder if we disable chat if it the
crashing stops before let's try spamming
shot again and see if it crashes again
purposely trying to like overload it
just yeah let's try it yeah let's try a
couple of things let's try everybody
just Spam chat emojis and [__] all right
I'm spamming build some pickles in chat
and then after that okay here let's kick
that off
let's try
um
uh
uh turning off chat
and seeing if that stops the crashing
you know
server overload let's get some pickles
in chat please
all I see is Dan I don't see anyone else
spamming
it's because they're on a delay
they'll understand in a second and
they'll join in all right yeah here
should be some more pickles any second
audio is slightly delayed oh we can do
slow mode someone suggested or I think
we are slow Mode's on yeah
okay so we have lots of spam coming on
here well actually I think their slow
mode is uh
is actually useless in our case because
I believe being a member
um gets you around it for some reason
which is really dumb
and we only have members that is so bad
everybody gets to go past the mode I
think I could be wrong okay let's stop
the spam we're gonna find out if it
worked or not
I mean
it doesn't man was pretty serious and it
doesn't seem to have caused a crime yeah
I don't think it's related people are
saying shout is frozen though disabled
but if you
just if you think the chat is it you the
audience can disable the chat and see
if they don't crash anymore I doubt it's
related to that
on your phone I don't think you can
disable it aren't we out here
troubleshooting for YouTube how many
times dude so annoying I do see people
saying crash but okay whatever let's
move on I can't talk about this crashing
[__] every day we've had enough
we've had enough so again we return to
the question and we'll redo the poll
it's do we join the blackout
yes or no
because yours says should we nuke the
subreddit
oh that's a bad pull that is a bad pull
you're right
it's part of the clickbait
do we join the blackout what button is
the seat again or do we walk our own
path
not necessarily in Defiance
Dana can you stop rambling to yourself
please I'm filling in for filling in for
Ian Dan is having his own private uh
dialogue
keyboard shortcuts are
you can ramble you can ramble to
yourself not into the mic Dan is jealous
of me
oh not on I don't know do we walk our
own path
or do we join the people
uh love can you make that poll since no
oh yeah sure at my station
okay here we go
this is it
everybody's watching Apollo is watching
everybody's watching the world famous
h3h3 production subreddit
is about to potentially join this
revolution
[Applause]
and now the people must vote
do we walk our own path like Jesus
Christ from Nazareth
or do we join the Sheep
and protest something that will never
change because the company doesn't even
make money
or
frame it a different way
do we join Spartacus
and stand up and say we are Spartacus
or do we side with the Roman Empire
which is gonna fall anyway
I'm Spartacus
no I am I can't start a ball done I'm
sparringus
oh
so we haven't done the poll
people are saying crit no nothing's
happening
nothing is happening
all right I'll set it up
thank you it's a great out for some
reason right now what the freaking Frick
dude dude it's 40K every time we get
there everybody crashes and it goes down
I'm telling you dude it's weird it's
like a 40K thing
swear to garsh the god emperor
is anybody on YouTube right now with
over 40K
live
like oh that's interesting let's look
into that there's somebody looking at
that okay I want to make sure we got a
good pull what's the wording
do we go dark do we go dark and
solidarity in solidarity
yeah yes or no
yes no
ask the community
pop it out
put it over here are we with the people
are we with the Roman Empire
yeah I mean the people they want people
support people you know you've got
Goliath which is Reddit
then you got Apollo
he's David kind of David you know
kind of yeah Paula was actually a Greek
god
not part of the uh abrahamic religious
Canon so if Paul is a Greek god kind of
like a war that could be like Zeus
yeah like Zeus Zeus and Hera and Apollo
and everybody versus no Zeus is most
father of Greek wait why are we mixing
our that's what I'm saying though
because Apollo is Greek mythology so I'm
trying to stick to the Greek so Apollo
versus Zeus
I don't know if they whatever is
established in the Canon
ever well do you consider God of War
Canon or no
all right so I guess this is it we're
going um
literally dude there's something with
the 40K whoa but there was crashes
before we hit like this is obviously
causing like a mass crash but I saw
people complaining about the crashing
before I do think it's happening also
but at 40K there's Mass crashes like we
haven't gone over the whole show which
makes no sense
well love what's the highest number
you're seeing the closest I'm even
seeing is 25k yeah I found a couple 20K
what are they
uh they're like one was uh some kind of
Capcom thing don't you think find it
fascinating that we are like by far the
number one live stream channel and
YouTube like doesn't [__] care about
us at all they're gonna listen to us
we're the number one podcast in the
world we I actually like that they don't
listen to us I'm like yo my stream is
crashing at every [__] minute and
they're like I don't care the number one
what the hell in the world
yeah a very big live stream is like a
show or or like a more official thing
like an event type thing yeah like new
C-SPAN footage or the biggest like
content creators Rumble dude oh wait but
you're saying I'm gonna go to rumble
they said thanks for this we flagged
this with our other teams that have been
trying to track down the issues sorry
there's not more to pass on as of right
now in terms of immediate fix let me say
or maybe I know this sounds strange
but we noticed
that whenever the live
number gets
close to 40K
there is a
Mass crash
and Chaos Gods we never cross 40K
it's Gandalf
all right so let's go dark
let's go dark
all right
in solidarity
with spez sticking it to the man get
your post in now guys because we are
going dark
why
why because spez is a douche
save changes
okay
that's it it's a private Community
it says on mine private community
you should update the text so it says my
beautiful boy Twisted Fantasy there it
is
does it say we'll be back and as part of
the uh yeah so how do I uh let me oh
I'll figure it out I don't know how to
change that but
there it is guys Community description
oh here we go all right
I designed that fan art piece of Love
shirt that's the H3 merch store it
started as a post on the subreddit I
don't know which one
I don't know which one you're talking
about
um thank you very much
so what are we saying uh our h3hp
Productions has gone dark
in
other people
that's in this okay thank you Julius
in protest
of reddit's
upcoming API changes yeah whatever
here's the live uh here's the live right
like go [__] yourself uh if you could
like Brian
yeah
we are see we're at the top yeah we're
at the top by far
oh this one has 29.
dude it's the 40K curse
Young Turks
embarrassing
embarrassing channels why don't they
okay whatever I can't talk about this
all day I can't so that's it okay thank
you we're dark
uh here try reloading it is my message
there now
uh H3 has gone dark in process of
reddit's upcoming API changes go [__]
yourself spez AKA Bad Luck Brian you
should write when we pick we'll be back
thank you we'll be back I'll be back
what's Wednesday's date the 14th 6 14
yeah thank you
14. so we should talk about the other
thing I wanted to talk about today was
um this Nick Merks anti the lgbtq
controversy that was happening
this was a big story and
I was interested in just because
I don't think people understand at all
what's going on here
uh for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar I guess
um this guy Nick Merks
he is a FaZe Clan member
who's up of course
in the words of asmen gold a bunch of
crackheads
which is aft phase
that's [__] up uh Nick is a twitch
streamer a YouTuber an owner of FaZe
Clan who plays fortnite and Warzone on
June 7th Nick Merks published a tweet in
response to a video of a massive brawl
taking place outside of a school in
Glendale California shout out Los
Angeles
the fight the fight was reportedly
sparked by a school board meeting
discussing the recognition of pride
month on campus which was approved by
unanimous decision later that day
and this turned into like a big uh
culture War thing
and then he said in response to I guess
a [__] riot again dude you want to
bet that all these psycho Mega dudes
just they don't even live here they
don't live here I mean plenty of the
people at the protest did but the
instigators and the people leading it
yeah are like professional uh
provocative they're here from Orange
County as we'll see
so
this happened uh four blocks from my
OverWatch League apartment Americans are
in a sad place right now let people live
and love and live their own life and
here you can see there's like it's
pretty violent anti-lgbt protesters
attack Pro LGBT demonstrators outside of
Glendale California Board school board
meeting where they recognize Jude as
pride month now what level of school is
this a high school is this a middle is
it Elementary School what are we talking
about the meeting was like a like the
board so it's it's the whole District
okay okay so here is uh the footage
like this this is come on now this is
stupid
this is just sad
and I'm telling you dude I know who
started this [__]
maybe it's I'm making this assumption
but I don't think it was the protect
trans kids guy who started throwing
punches I don't
I just don't oh um and then here's their
shirts the ones starting the fight
their shirt says leave our kids alone
that's how this whole thing is Being
Framed leave our kids alone
by recognizing pride month okay so so
Nick uh phase
Nick Merks
says they should leave little children
alone that's the real issue
and it got 83 000 likes people were like
yeah leave the kids alone
now I'm going to explain the problem
with this statement and the reason why I
disagree with leave kids alone exactly
on its face is like yeah leave the kids
alone yeah uh Pink Floyd said it first
damn you're right don't even think about
it like that
so uh the Glendale School District put
out a fact sheet of why they are trying
what they're trying to teach
they have the key points they're trying
to discuss
I'll get to that but Nick Merks
essentially after this tweet
um
his skins or I guess he has some kind of
bundle or something in the Modern
Warfare too
so they put out a statement due to the
recent events we have removed Nick
Merk's operator bundle for Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone store Activision
confirmed on June 8th
now I'll say
do here they go uh
I guess these people announced it first
and they said yeah we deleted that [__]
now I'll say this
oh here's gays against groomers in the
that's Ollie London's [__] uh
of course he's here
uh all the man said was leave kids alone
we agree
right so we gotta ask what's on the hard
drive of whoever was behind these
decisions [__] what's on your hard
drive Ollie London you freak
[__] you what's on the hard drive please
bro again murder porn if you go talk to
the murder porn guy go talk to the local
uh pastor
it's about time we send the pastors out
to pasture
I gotta say my pun game since becoming a
dad is really elevated
it really has
this is something every single person
should agree with you are vile and we
hope this bankrupts you of course
everybody agrees but that's not the
[__] problem the problem is the
framing of it
okay dumbass these guys are such jokes
who's actually following this account
golly
early London
murder porn
okay so this caused enough now I'll see
maybe it was a little bit of
overreaction
I mean the guy's an idiot I think he's
an ignoramus
he responded a day after all the
backlash and like I stand by what I said
I'm sorry they doubled down on it and
also the timing you know this is during
all these companies big it's pride month
it's pride month you can't do that on
Prime month I mean like would they have
dropped the skin if it didn't happen in
June I'm gonna go ahead and guess that
they probably wouldn't give a [__] I I
there may have been people inside the
company who are like yo [__] this and
you know they came in June this year
they care about their employees and
they're like okay but they're they're
within the right because at the end of
the day I agree
that even though it doesn't seem like it
this is a deep it is a homophobic and a
transphobic comment and the problem is I
know this guy doesn't see himself as
being hateful and that's where a lot of
these disconnects come from
here's a
Ron DeSantis supporter by the way not
even Maga Ron DeSantis he thinks is the
goat which is so [__] funny to me
like the dude that thinks Rhonda Ron
White boots wrong white boots this guy's
goat his feet look like gold feet which
really tells you a lot
well regardless I'm sure that this guy
when he looks at himself in the mirror
he doesn't see uh he doesn't see a
person who's like I hate gay people I
hate trans people he thinks he's a
reasonable guy and he knows he go I
don't hate people and this is where the
problem is a lot of people have a hard
time looking at themselves and saying
what this opinion is doing the result of
this is ignorant and it's creating hate
in the world I've had that realization
with myself you know it's not easy to
see that because we don't we don't
that's not how we feel when we look in
the mirror we all think hey we're decent
people we do our best to be nice be good
humans
but it's important to be critical about
how we're interacting with things so uh
here he is he says by the way it is
interesting too of a bunch of like
protesters getting the [__] beat out of
them by like Maga freaks
they should leave the kids alone that's
the real issue okay
so uh look back to the dock here
let's take a look first at the fact
sheet that Glendale School District put
out
so they put this out in response to the
fact that in all of these like uh
psycho-parent groups that were getting
all upset a bunch of
memes and false information about what
was being taught at the school was going
around so they just wanted to clarify
this is actually what we're
talking about when we're having this
discussion so here's the key points uh
Glendale school district has a process
for selecting your curriculum and
instructional materials we intentionally
include diverse voices and lessons in
our curriculum supplemental materials
yada yada
to understand adversity of peers
Elementary curriculum related to
diversity including LGBT plus issues is
focused on highlighting all different
types of families Elementary curriculum
does not include specific information
about gender or
LGBT or gender identity
just basically saying some people have
two dads which that's normal I guarantee
you there are people at that school that
have gay parents I'm gay
actually I'm not and and there's also
people at these schools who are
questioning
their own sexuality and their own gender
identity amazing
uh so Administration teachers are
trusted to use professional judgment
when deciding a particular topic is
suitable
yada yada yada key points uh
grade five development and maturation
focuses on body changes occur during
puberty boys and girls are separated
into two different rooms and shown as 16
the 20 minute video typically by the
school nurse some schools provide a
video link to parents to show at home in
lieu of watching
uh the video at school grades seven and
nine so that literally correct me if I'm
wrong I didn't go to the Glendale School
District I went to LAUSD but
that policy has existed at least since I
was in the fifth grade because I had
that class in fifth grade I remember
that the first like sex ed class yes I
was in fifth grade in Michigan and I
watched yeah so this is literally just
standard [__] [__] amazing but I
don't know if that's the part they're
protesting they say grades seven and
nine seconds well now they're
instructions this is grooming to them
now
is that what they're saying I know
they're just they don't like them and
the fact that they acknowledge that gay
people exist that's grooming too
I mean the reality is they're they're
getting mad about things that aren't
really happening and that's why I think
it's useful to look at this and see what
what we're this conversation is actually
about because I would really invite Nick
Merks or whatever to read through this
and specifically say what the problem is
well okay so uh let's see gender
identity and pronouns this is the new
stuff that wasn't there when I was in
school this is probably something they
have a problem with these protesters
Glendale School District policies
followed a lot require the signature of
parents or Guardians before school
official School record has changed since
2013 state laws mandated that students
have a right to ask to be referred by a
name or pronoun that might be different
than what's on their official record a
school may not question the student's
asserted gender identity disclosing a
student is transgender without the
student's permission May violate
California anti-discrimination law a
school must protect children from being
teased for failing to conform to sex
stereotypes including being delivered
deliberately referred to by the name and
or pronouns associated with the students
assigned sex worth I mean this is
clearly designed to protect students
I don't see it what could possibly be
bad about that yeah
okay so anyway so this is what they're
freaking out about well the last part is
probably something they're freaking out
about too it's the locker room stuff and
like bathrooms and everything which
obviously is a big thing but if you
actually read what they say I think it's
completely [__] reasonable California
law requires that students shall have
access to restrooms and locker rooms
that correspond to their gender identity
all Glendale School District locker
rooms are equipped with private changing
facilities for any student who wishes to
use them no student is ever forced to
disrobert change clothes in front of any
other students great
private room again it's like if anybody
actually just looked at what the
conversation actually was I mean
obviously some people would still have a
problem with it but
when it's just this vague oh they're
grooming they're grooming these kids and
it's like just look at what we're
actually talking about here like who has
a problem with this so here here's what
I'll say
this is why I think these kinds of
statements are [__] up
they should leave the children alone
that's the real issue
there's a context there
that is implying
that they are coming for children who's
coming for children gay Advocates trans
people LGBT in general they're coming
for children
it's part of an agenda of them to force
some ideology on them
now what this narrative does
is it it's like the
the front door of homophobia and
transphobia this is like the Gateway
once you're willing to accept this
premise that there is a group of people
who are trying to push their ideas onto
children then you're willing to believe
almost anything at that point about
trans people and gay people that they're
groomers that they're um
that they're all pedophiles you hear
that it
it's it's it's outrageous and so this
claim that they should leave children
alone
it's directly going to cause a ton of
transphobia and homophobia now here's
where this becomes so silly
now they're saying June is pride month
they're recognizing that in the school
district there's a Black History Month
that schools recognize is that
indoctrinating
is that do we need to leave the children
alone when it comes to Black History
Month well
a lot of these people probably would say
yes to that too because that's that's
critical race Theory
there would be a lot less people who
would be comfortable yeah for sure for
sure but your your right to draw the
parallel there and then I think what
they would say is well black history
doesn't have anything to do with
sexualization and I would say neither
does pride month it is about a um
a marginalized group that historically
has been through a whole bunch of
[__] [__] and it's about recognizing
them and normalizing it in the sense
that they're not looked as
Outsiders or weirdos or freaks so that
30 to 50 of trans kids aren't attempting
to commit suicide
because that is definitely the societal
pressure that makes them feel like
freaks
and so
there's a lot like this this argument
could be extended to a lot of things
they should leave the children alone I
mean you can make that argument about
almost anything in the curriculum
there's no consistency about it the
truth is that they just don't like gay
people they don't like trans people and
this is how it's manifested even if
they're aware of it or if they're not
this is the result of this because it
you know that's what school is what do
you mean leave the children alone what
do you want them to do just it's all
indoctrinization right we don't have any
problem indoctrinating them into like
American history or you know ideology
capitalism like that's school we trust
our Educators like listen
education it's a well
uh established disciplined people study
it they get Master's reason we trust the
professionals to educate our kids so
when you say leave the little kids alone
you're saying essentially if you work it
out all the way they're just you want
them to just go sit there and stare at
the wall because everything they
teaching them is from some kind of
[__] perspective
so so what does it mean to leave the
children alone
what does it mean ultimately at the end
of the day also I think I think we
skipped down the fact sheet before we
got to the specific point but the the
one part that like somebody that you
know is very socially conservative would
maybe take issue with is I want those
conversations are for me to have with my
kid not why to be taught by a teacher
well but listen it says in the policy
and I remember this being the case too
when we had the sex ed class or whatever
I had to get uh what do you call it
permission for my parents and they say
in the thing me too but but again you
can opt out even that in that class
listen even that is homophobic and
transphobic because
learning about
lgbtq rights
isn't sexual it's the same as any other
marginalized groups same about this uh
hearing about Native American
discrimination and and uh genocide it's
about it's same as learning about
African-American history it's the same
about learning about Chinese people who
are
second-class citizens the same about
Japanese people who put in internment
camp are all these indoctrinating the
only reason you're singling this one out
is because you're homophobic and you're
transphobic that is the only reason
that's it and so it seems like an
innocent statement and you might look at
that on face value and say yeah of
course that's so obvious leave the
children alone that's so obvious who
would have disagree with that but the
truth is it is it's [__] up it's super
[__] up and it's a gateway
and it's a veiled it's it's lightly
veiled maybe heavily veiled homophobia
transphobia because on the face
it looks reasonable but when you analyze
it it has no merit none at all it's
silly [__]
and it's gross man you know back when I
was there was less people caring about
this ship I feel like when I was a kid
than there is now
all of a sudden like homophobia is back
baby
like
it's CR it's [__] up man it's
absolutely mental what's going on here
so I think it just is ex because
it was very much present when we were
kids I think weirdly it's the fact that
more people are more accepting of it
that's raised like the viciousness of it
and like the the spilling out into
violence because there was that I mean
people were definitely I think on the
whole much more homophobic when I was
growing up than they are now
yeah when you agree yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely yeah but because there
are more people willing to push back
it's also causing the reactionaries to
become much more adamant and violent
about their uh bigotry I guess you see
the same thing when uh
African-Americans got more rights you
see the put and more acceptance right
you see the pushback from see the push
back more that's the rubber band exactly
and as gay people got the federal right
to uh to marry then I guess the
extremists are coming out of the
woodwork but it's disturbing to see
mainstream people they don't realize
maybe he doesn't realize what he's
saying or what he's doing because then
here so Nick Merck started this
and then a ton of people started come
out to back him up
um
here's a doctor disrespect uninstalled
Call of Duty for his buddy Nick Merks
the gamers are rising up dude Dr
disrespect has uninstalled Call of Duty
he says unless they apologize and
reinstate bundle he won't be playing the
game number one
like I get that you want to stick up for
your friend and maybe it's true they
overreacted that's that I would be
willing to to debate but
you can't uncritically analyze what he
said because ultimately by normalizing
what he said to the airport of young
audience
you are giving credibility to this
homophobic transphobic argument that
teaching Pride a marginalized group is
inherently indoctrination that's [__]
insane here
is uninstall the game no number one dork
I mean don't get a mistake in this
year's Call of Duty is the worst in its
franchise
uh all the Ever
but that decision
my cod's PR marketing team
oh
uh Gamers rise up
[Music]
you can always count on Gamers to make
the worst possible doesn't he also thank
you 5G cell phone signals uh give you
covet or something I don't know if
that's a joke or not I never know man I
understand I think he might actually be
serious about some of that stuff that's
a tough one to digest for the two-time
what's the what's the rock that he's
always Ian would know
that's not serious is it here
uh who knows right you don't know I
think it might be serious that's what I
thought wait what I think it's kind of
serious
sure no fresh fresh baguette Ian knows a
lot more about the the doc lore than I
do no I agree uh if he says it's serious
I agree uh fresh baguette says leave our
kids alone applies that all kids are CIS
and straight as someone who was gay kid
in fifth grade I felt like there was
something really wrong with me since
there was no talk of gay people exactly
exactly we you need to embrace and
explain the diversity that we experience
otherwise you are hurting kids you are
hurting kids and again
you guys gotta grapple with this stat
which is so alarming 30 to 50 of
transgender kids attempt suicide I mean
what the [__] that's that come on
this is like unacceptable they need to
apologize really crazy that
conservatives hear pride and all they
think is sex like what what
about it's people just love each other
and it's it did [__] straight couples
have sex too when kids read books about
a mom and dad they're not like oh [__]
like I'm teaching my kid about having
sex but if it's a dad and a dad it's
like oh they're all having sex they're
having gay sex gross they want our kids
to have gay sex yeah what the [__] no
it's it it's demented
it's demented that's why I compare it to
Black History Month it's a marginalized
group that we as a society need to come
to terms with and understand so we can
have a more prosperous and peaceful and
understanding Society
um doctor disrespectful is more
respectful to his homies than his wife
says Avery and that's a pretty good
point
also somebody in the chat pointed out
that he didn't uh
he got in some legal trouble for filming
a bunch of people in a bathroom oh yeah
I remember kind of groomer Behavior well
if we're gonna if we're obsessing over
trans and back kind of weird kind of
weird to walk into a bathroom with a
camera and just start filming a bunch of
uh yeah
it's publicly to him
or reinstate his bundle
in order for me to consider playing Call
of Duty again that's where I'm at
[Music]
we just don't
uh
and for them this is like easy virtue
signaling because most of these kids
don't understand
you know it's just the easiest [__]
virtue signal in the world and whenever
the new call like there's zero
zero percent chance than when the new
Call of Duty comes out these guys aren't
playing true
uh Tim the tat man I think
I think I'm
face Twitter friends with this guy
sounds familiar I feel like he's come up
on the show before he streams a lot with
Ninja
so here's the drama with him like oh
yeah I assume something about baby TV I
think
during that whole thing
I think we do follow each other so
listen it's not personal
but I've explained I think pretty in
depth about what my problem is here
he says Nick Merks has been my friend
for years he went
in getting our Cod operators together it
feels wrong for me to have mine
and him no longer have his in support of
my friend please remove the Tim the tap
mad bundle
okay it's more solidarity with his
friend but
250 250 000 likes yo yo erase my [__]
bro they probably didn't even erase this
is not if he really wanted to he would
send have to send them a legal letter or
something this tweet I think they did
erase it they did okay I think so but
also I feel like this is telling I think
maybe they didn't make very much money
from the from the skin instead of like
ah we can we can sound good but also
don't lose that much money well they're
probably old I mean I can't imagine
people yeah exactly buying it still I
mean if you care return the money or
donate it to uh donate it to uh the uh
Kenneth Copeland fund
yeah prove that you really hate trans
people it was removed yesterday
Tim's uh bundle Hallelujah so I don't
know
again he's supporting his friend but
he's not being critically examining
what's happening here this is just like
absolute virtue singling of the highest
order 250
000 likes
dude here's a top comment it's
interesting do these guys have no idea
to pride month the lack of empathy and
self-awareness would be hilarious if it
weren't so sad these people had such big
platforms
they don't yeah here's train wreck my
boy
my boy train wrecks in the comments
uh W [__] cancel culture
oh my God you know what the time Cancel
culture what are you talking about train
wreck two years ago
like damn [__] it's still happening yeah
with the [__] we we've already
decided cancel culture is good now we're
canceling but light we're canceling
Target we're canceling this [__] if
cancer culture was real you would you
wouldn't have a career brother yeah
they're canceling Call of Duty oh yeah
W if the part of the internet that's
going on after mercs were the good guys
quote they teach and be patient even if
their teachings are being questioned
that is what I'm doing I mean
I I'm I'm willing to say that it may
have been an overreaction for them to do
it
the vocal minority who pretend that they
are fighting for equality are just
virtue signaling for clout
what they are doing here with this
situation only sends people further down
the rabbit hole and divides by putting
people into an angry State void of logic
and understanding political leaders and
viewers coming after him know this
and use these movements for their own
gain power and advertisement
yeah this I hear that a lot the only
reason you could ever criticize him
is uh you you know you're wrong you know
you're wrong
train wreck you are like the biggest
piece of [__] in the [__] world
you literally how many like how many
people's lives have you ruined directly
and profited off of like shut your
[__] mouth about any social issue
dude you have no ground to stand on I
would not be surprised if literally
suicides were were a [__] result of
what you've been putting out in the
world gambling which is the deadliest
Vice like you have no [__] bro shut the
[__] up in order to comprehend you're
gonna have to break some don't break the
[__] like comprehend this guy has
like the thinnest possible ground to
stand on on any moral social issue give
me a break co-owner of kick.com those
eggshells didn't he wasn't he pretending
like he didn't wasn't an owner
definitely definitely remembered him
saying I'm not an owner he says I just
have advisory shares now he's co-owner
of pick.com you are such a shady liar
loser
zero [__] accountability you have no
you are such a loser man
it's actually incredible
love you
oh yeah Chad asks are we really
surprised that Cod players are
homophobic yeah again that's the game
we're having a gamer moment here for
sure
but there it is uh I I try to break that
down in a sense because I don't think
people understand why what he said is
[__] up so I'm I'm endeavoring to
explain it those eggshells I'm sure they
will not listen
uh in fact
I'm positive
I do feel like they're not sorry you go
ahead I'm under the light okay I was
gonna say these are not your typical
Gamers either these are like [__]
grown-up millionaires with kids with
families even though it's your average
[__] 13 14 15 16 year old edgy
teenager there's like grown ass men bro
yeah 30s yeah
FaZe Rain is in the comments no that's
[__] up
oh [__] you know FaZe Rain knows what's
[__] up and what isn't
nah that's [__] up yo he wrote that
nah that get it's so funny to me that
they talk about virtue signaling and
here they are with the
easiest [__] signal
yeah which again none of them are not
going to play Call of Duty that's virtue
signal it's completely like you're all
gonna play the new Call of Duty when it
comes out guaranteed a hundred percent
train wreck comes in now let me tell you
why this is wrong
you literally live in an ivory Tower
like have you seen where he lives it's
like the top floor of the panoramic view
it's like you live in an ivory Tower
built on the souls of children you've
harvested let me tell you why this is
morally wrong shut the [__] up dude
no not fousey
no I feel this hold on this might be
personal to fousey uh Zach
he is a member I think of the I felt
worthless of the community I felt ugly
well he felt like he was
go ahead
I felt gay
that was good that was the new one this
is such [__] fousey says didn't he
just say keep the kids out of this again
I I yes I've gone to Great Lengths to
explain why that's [__] up and I hope
everyone understands they literally want
us programmed to only say what fits the
agenda again the gay agenda what what
agenda that's it that's right I the gay
agenda the Jewish agenda it's literally
it's it's as bad that's why I felt it
was so important to pull up that
document that actually shows what is you
know what the policy that everybody
because it none of these people
including Nick Merks and then it only
gets further removed the further down
the chain of these people even know what
the [__] we're talking about it's just
like that's why it's such a [__] up
statement yeah and if some from someone
so influential it it's the Gateway
now it trickles down and people like
dude what is wrong with these with this
gay agenda
and everybody the same sex ed classes
that they've been teaching for 25 years
and by the way at least just to show you
what virtue signaling [__] this is I
guarantee you this is his most liked
tweet in like months fact check that who
fousey Lucy yeah
everybody's getting like their fattest
Twitter dub by saying like gay agenda
[Music]
Grace Van Dean coming with a W though
FaZe Grace
it would be nice to have it available
presented discussed in schools for kids
that don't have open-minded parents shut
the [__] up
big gamer
yeah that's not a gamer girl gamer girl
alert that is not a gamer opinion I
would 100 love to have a conversation
with Tim the tatman or well I don't know
what's his opinion he's just backing up
his friend or Nick Merks because I do
feel like if we had a conversation and I
explained why what he said is [__] up
yeah he would go Point by Point through
that that document and just be like
which parts of this is a problem for you
he would be forced to confront what in
my opinion is obviously
inconsistent
so if he wants to I'd love to talk to
him you know what I mean
he's open for that based on what I'm
seeing you are correct that is fuzzi's
most liked tweet by far there even his
pin tweet about being sober for a year
uh just no one cares sober for a year
nobody cares wait wait wait how many
likes hanging up on gay people how much
likes now the solo uh uh the sober one
have uh the sober one has uh 3 800 likes
worthless and how much does his uh gay
agenda one have that is over nine
thousand over nine thousand do you see
what I'm saying
this is the height of virtue signaling
we are here they just need to tweet
about you next and then he'll be he'll
be back I'll be back on top Vibes like
like that tells that tells me a lot
that tells me a lot
Ollie London's in the comments being
like yeah I support you that's that's
how you know you [__] up
I
see people in the chat suggesting why
don't they teach trick shots in school
that's a good point that's an
interesting curriculum yeah
maybe that's a way to kind of bridge the
gap
you know like a compromise in a way like
we won't compromise on on teaching you
know that gay people exist in school but
like if we dedicated 45 minutes a day to
like you know sick 360 no scope
tutorials
then maybe maybe you want to be such a
big deal you know maybe not Call of Duty
but maybe just guns in general maybe oh
you know focus on that right yeah I do
think it would be cool if we could do
trick shots IRL
right
because we're going in a video game is
kind of poser [__] I got a little gay I
got you don't worry
aye trick shots and IRL ready you gonna
shoot us at home join in
uh oh oh [__]
yeah that was [__] sick MLG as [__]
wasted
um so that's it I let's reach out to him
maybe he's down to have a conversation
it'd be great Nick Merks maybe maybe why
what could be bad about it no I I don't
I don't have any opposition to talking
to him I just don't necessarily think
that he would want oh yeah no I I yeah
because you're [__] libtard fat loser
I'm part of the gay and Jewish agenda
right
yeah but let's reach out I mean why not
maybe he's down to have a conversation
and I think it could be really
productive and maybe he'll convince me
that maybe there is a gay agenda who
knows
you know what I'm saying
that's good maybe he'll just maybe he's
right
you know maybe there are Kitty boxes in
uh right where Kitty uh Kitty folks can
take a [__]
Kitty Kim
uh all right we are at three and a half
hours since the controversy Nick's Merks
of course is growing rapidly on Twitter
people love our boy yes he's up he's the
man he's up he's up leave the kids alone
why won't they leave them alone
[Music]
the gay agenda
man's got a thick neck yep
got a neck agenda
leave my kids alone with that neck
agenda he kissed his old nasty pig
stinking neck
but here's the thing
and again Nick if you're seeing this I
don't think you're like I hate that's
what I'm saying when you look in the
mirror you don't see a hateful person
you're probably a really nice guy the
people in your life people around you
they go yeah he's a great guy I'm a nice
guy
that's part of what's so difficult about
this
right
it's so hard to see through the veil
that you're doing something that has is
having a negative effect on people
uh
but I would love to talk to you
people in the chat are saying that uh
Hassan took a crack at that
and uh he took a crack at what talking
to Nick Merks I guess he talked to him
oh he did how'd that go from what I'm
gathering in the chat it sounds like it
wasn't publicly like he talked to him in
DMS or something
and he was not able to uh that's not
this breakthrough I don't think it's not
the same conversation I could be
misunderstanding that though uh so let
me know let's reach out had him on
stream or something yeah let's reach out
yeah maybe he wants travel combo I think
it's at least worthwhile for him I mean
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
I think I got it yeah yeah I mean
definitely you hit it right after
he's up I don't think Dan's I don't
think he buttoned me once
no ironically I mean you've become way
more triggered that once again just that
was not that necessary of a button
crickets man
but um
I'll DM him let me see if Nick Merks
follows me
Tim the tat man uh again nothing
personal
and again you you were just backing your
homie up so I don't even think it's
necessarily
something you would even why did Tim the
tat man what was
I'm talking years ago four years ago
five years ago we had some
drama was he in drama with like one of
the Paul brothers or something let's
check the Reddit you know what I'm
talking about Ian
not ringing a bell no
you think I'm Tim the toolman Taylor
Maybe maybe it was another like phase
dude with a t name
how do you reach out to this guy Olivia
what's your process
um I'll either look for their booking
agent info or if they're a content
creator I'll usually reach out via the
Instagram from for the Pod oh that's
smart you can also tweet at them from
the Pod oh I've never done that I'll do
that yeah that's good that you can do
that
um
he actually has been popping off I guess
on Twitter
uh Nick
what is it Nick Merks
phase up
food's up
okay agenda down phase up blanks here he
he tweeted 180 000 likes friends are
created in good times but families
they're built through adversity
that's some that's some fast and furious
[__] if I've ever read it appreciate all
of you having my back understanding my
position as a new father
yeah as a new father I don't want my son
hearing about that gay [__]
and recognize the love I have for all no
hate again no hate in this heart I I
agree you know that's I agree that you
hit us with the peace and love
wait what yeah p l p and l that's the
family what the [__] dude if that takes
off if this p l thing takes off we can
in my opinion single-handed League take
credit for this cultural phenomenon I
was watching Dave Pac-Man yesterday and
he said with peace and love
interest or something yeah definitely
not the guy from The Beatles yeah I mean
Ringo did start it yeah no I think you
could sue for this
you know what I mean maybe yeah I know
it's just a very common phrase it was a
Stern thing what was it yeah and also
didn't you get it from Stern dude no
Howard's been talking about like
nobody's [__] everybody's been
talking about peace and love forever now
that's such [__] people on YouTube
are not doing peace and love that's on
YouTube specifically it's just younger
people the world in general my
grandfather was wearing a shirt that
said peace and love maybe he was from
the future yeah no but the what things
maybe I'm like John Connor back in the
1960s
I'm sorry no you guys are [__] with
me
get out of here
[__] uh [__] forgot to update y'all my B
shooting a commercial today bad [__]
[__] won't be live okay whatever
Big B for tomorrow
oh you put that neck away
it's dangerous making me insecure
am I being groomed right now
okay there it is
his engagement before getting into the
uh the gay agenda
let's see
one thousand eight hundred
two thousand six hundred
three thousand six hundred
now he's getting like 200 000 likes okay
agenda
[Music]
yo
y'all heard about this gay agenda
but don't even get me started on the
Jewish agenda
that's right
oh did I mention the uh
Christian the Evangelical uh agenda
you know the group of people that just
lobbied and [__] like planted the
Supreme Court to make abortion
illegal across the whole [__] country
they have an agenda no no
[Applause]
no no no you want to hear about this
Muslim agenda we got um
would it be inappropriate if yep
should I type it
uh it was just a joke but maybe I
shouldn't have said it I didn't say it
anyway whatever so that's the show
that's it
you know who should really leave the
kids alone
who the [__] military recruiters at
high school groomers the actual [__]
weirdo literally the actual groomers
you're trying to take my kids and kill
them bro yeah yo and for what like like
for thirty thousand dollars a year right
that's true you want to talk about
grooming they don't even work for the
[__] school dude and then they come
home with black lung cancer from Burn
pits and Trauma from [__] killing
villagers keep our kids safe and then
they end up living on the street where
people can tell can come back and tell
them what piece of [__] lowlifes they
are it's awesome new Ela Vlogs out by
the way
the 35 year old recruiter no plans after
school haha that's a shame you act so
mature for your age what's your
malfunction Soldier your parents know
about the benefits you get from serving
wow I would have never guessed you were
that young ha ha no don't go to college
first you're so strong and poor though
you're spending so much time with your
friends you should spend that time in
the Middle East that sucks you grew up
without a dad haha
if you guys want the new ELO Vlog it's
spicy it's hot it's happening it's
everything
onto Ethan and Ela uh Webb's Channel hey
guys we hired this is the pope we had on
it's in time we actually well I guess
the cat's out of the bag now because we
didn't post yet but we made the Poke
Puffer
the viral pup puffer right so I guess we
can explain this is why the pope just
randomly was here last Wednesday yeah
Ethan was like we got a poke here we
gotta do something with them
yeah exactly so uh he we did a photo
shoot with this Pope in the pope puffer
which I think is pretty far
I think it's good content
and uh he was talking about stuff it's a
nice experience everyone having a good
time
yeah there it is thank you check it out
all right guys today is Monday so
um tomorrow
is uh see you next Tuesday
yes yeah so members thank you to our
wonderful beautiful members who do so
much for the show in this community I
thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart and it's my pleasure to have the
live stream for you guys tomorrow see
you next Tuesday we always have a lot of
fun
and then Wednesday we'll be back oh do
we when is uh we have a special guest
was that on Wednesday yes let's talk
about after the show though yes
some updates
okay guys so members see you tomorrow
everyone else Wednesday thanks for
watching have a great week everybody
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]